So Willie and I are in New York right now surviving this blizzard. I know this is going to come out later, but it's pretty rough out there. Yeah. I got out of there on Saturday. I got very lucky. I was doing a cold open. Yeah, we're just in the middle of my open. Oh, you're doing a cold open.
所以威利和我现在在纽约，正在经历这场暴风雪。我知道这集节目会晚点播出，但外面天气真的很糟。对啊。我星期六就离开那儿了。我太幸运了。我当时正在做开场脱口秀。对，我们正说到我的开场。哦，你在做一个开场脱口秀。
Oh, sorry, sorry. We'll get back to you. I don't know. I'm smart. I never saw Field of Dreams. Yeah, and Scotty put it up. And he's like, I was like, yeah, let's watch this. I never saw it.
哦，抱歉，抱歉。我们一会儿再找你。我不知道。我很聪明。我从来没看过《梦幻田野》。对，斯科蒂把它放出来了。然后他说，我就觉得，好吧，我们看这个吧。我从没看过。
Like, it's, yeah, have you seen it? Well, hang on. And did you, so he built it, you came. Really nice, Jason. Bravo, bravo. What did you think of it, Sean? I thought it was so good. I thought the tone was really good.
就像是，对，你看过吗？好吧，等等。然后你，所以他建了球场，你去了。真棒，杰森。太棒了，太棒了。肖恩，你觉得怎么样？我觉得非常好。我觉得基调真的很棒。
I thought. Oh, don't need a detailed review. No, I thought it was, first of all, I didn't know what it was. I mean, I've seen clips about, in clips of it like over the decades. So I kind of had an idea, and I've, of course, known the phrase, build it, and he will come whenever. But I never... I'm sure I've ever seen it.
我觉得。哦，不需要详细的评价。不，我觉得，首先，我不知道那是什么。我是说，过去几十年里我见过它的片段。所以我大概有个概念，而且我当然知道“你建好了，他就会来”这句台词，无论何时。但我从来没……我确信我从来没看过。
Oh, we got to watch it. It's really, really good. You'd watch it for a second time. I would. Wow. Have them over to your theater, J.B. Yeah. Come on over.
哦，我们得看看。真的非常非常好看。你会愿意看第二遍的。我愿意。哇。让他们去你的私人影院吧，杰比。对。过来吧。
So you've never seen it, Jason. I don't think I have, no. I don't know if I've ever seen Major League, and I don't know if I've ever seen Bull Durham. And I'm like this huge baseball. Well, this is a baseball. Yeah, I know I've seen the natural bunch of times. Bull Durham is excellent.
所以你从没看过，杰森。我想我没看，没有。我不知道我有没有看过《大联盟》，我也不知道我有没有看过《百万金臂》。而我其实是个棒球迷。好吧，这是一部棒球片。对，我知道我看过好多次《天生好手》。《百万金臂》非常优秀。
Yeah. I've never seen any of it. I love Bulldo. Maybe I'll just see little clips of it on social media. Yeah, and then just piece it together. That's a good way to do it. Like my kids, you're like kind of 20 seconds at a time. Yeah, this is the way the kids are eating stuff up nowadays.
对。我从来没看过任何片段。我喜欢《百万金臂》。也许我只是在社交媒体上看过它的剪辑小片段。对，然后自己拼凑起来。这倒是个好办法。就像我的孩子们，你大概是一次看20秒。对，现在的孩子们就是这样消遣的。
What do you guys think about that? They're making those little clips. Isn't there like one minute episodes now of stuff? Have you heard about this? Is it maybe on Tooby? Do I have Tooby? You do. You do currently have To be.
你们对这个怎么看？他们在制作那些小剪辑。现在不是有什么一分钟的小剧集吗？你们听说过这个吗？是不是在Tubi上？我有Tubi吗？你有的。你目前确实有Tubi。
No, but you guys, does anybody know about this? Quibi. Quibi. Quibi was the first thing, but then, you know, that didn't work out for whatever reason. So there's one-minute episodes of stuff? Yeah, and now that's really, that's what I read, that it's really picking up on TikTok. And they'll do, like, a whole season is five minutes. Really?
不，但是你们，有人知道这个吗？Quibi。Quibi。Quibi是第一个推出的，但是呢，不管出于什么原因，它没成功。所以现在有一分钟的剧集？对，现在真的，我看到报道说它在TikTok上非常火。他们会把一整季浓缩成五分钟。真的吗？
And each episode is, like, a minute or two minutes. It must be riveting. You haven't heard about that? That can't be a good thing. I actually haven't, I have not heard of it. Michael Bennett, Rob, have you heard about that? Oh, yeah. Yeah.
而且每集大概只有一分钟或两分钟。那一定很引人入胜。你们没听说过这事吗？这不可能是件好事。我其实真的没听说过。迈克尔·贝内特、罗布，你们听说过吗？哦，是的。对。
Verticles. Well, Rob, first of all, take the judgment out of your voice when you say, oh, yeah. We need to work on our attention span. all of us on this planet, right? I know. I think we need to watch stuff that's longer. I think that that's been... Longer, slower.
竖屏短剧。好吧，罗布，首先，当你用“哦，是的”这种语气时，请收起你语气里的评判。我们需要锻炼我们的注意力。我们这个星球上的所有人，对吧？我知道。我觉得我们需要看一些更长的内容。我觉得这一直是……更长，更慢。
Everybody watch Field of Dreams. That all the tech billionaires don't, they really limit their kids' access to short-form stuff because they realize that there's studies that show it has a direct impact on kids. That's well, I don't know. Well, listen, this is helpful then today
大家都去看看《梦幻田野》。所有的科技亿万富翁不都这样吗，他们真的限制了孩子们接触短视频内容，因为他们意识到有研究表明这会对孩子们产生直接影响。好吧，我不知道。好吧，听着，那今天就很有用了，
because what I've got with us today is somebody who might be able to opine on some of these things and give us a look around the corner a little bit for what might be coming, you know. With us today is a leader of an empire. Ooh. She has launched and is the guiding force behind at least 10 companies by my count,
因为我今天请到的这位嘉宾，或许能对其中一些事情发表高见，并为我们对未来的趋势作一点前瞻性的展望，你知道的。今天和我们在一起的是一个商业帝国的掌门人。哦。据我统计，她一手创立并掌舵了至少10家公司，
which generated dollars in the billions, I'm sure. Her business skills and know-how are matched only by our media savvy and cultural instincts. Her abilities as a manager and a parent, however, is where it all started. Here to tell us how on earth she does it and where it all goes from here is the one, the only, Chris Jenner. Oh, look at the first.
创造的财富肯定有数十亿美元之多。她的商业技能和精明强干，只有她的媒体敏锐度和文化直觉能够匹敌。然而，她作为管理者和母亲的出色能力，才是一切的起点。今天来到这里，向我们讲述她到底是怎么做到的，以及这一切将走向何方的，是独一无二的克里斯·詹娜。哦，看第一眼。
Chris? Hey, guys. I am very excited that you are with us today. I've wanted you on the show for, you know, very, very long time. I've been afraid to ask you. We're travel buddies. We go on vacation together. We are a little bit.
克里斯？嘿，伙计们。我很高兴你们今天能来。我一直想让你上节目，你知道的，已经很久很久了。我一直不敢开口。我们是旅行伙伴。我们一起去度假。我们确实算一点吧。
Jason and I. Is that true? And Amanda. Yeah, we do. Yeah. We kind of plan it, but it's an accident. Yeah. So I'll let you guys figure that one out.
杰森和我。真的吗？还有阿曼达。对，我们会的。对。我们算是计划好的，但也是个意外。好吧，那就让你们自己去琢磨吧。
Yeah. Okay. Oh, it's just fascinating to talk to. and I'm really, really happier you're with us today. Thank you. All right. Let me just like, could you, there's no way you could imagine that your adult life would be here where we are now. I would imagine.
好吧。好的，跟（你）聊天真的太迷人了，我真的、真的很高兴你今天能跟我们在一起。谢谢。好吧。让我想想，你能想象吗，你的成年生活会是现在这个样子，走到我们今天所在的这个位置。我想象不到。
What did you think you were going to be when you grew up? Was there an early idea, plan, goal, dream? A mom. Yeah? Oh, really. I used to dream about being a mom. When I was 16, I decided I wanted six kids. No way.
你小时候觉得自己长大后会成为什么样的人？有没有早期的想法、计划、目标或梦想？一个妈妈。是吗？哦，真的吗。我过去常常梦想成为一个妈妈。当我16岁时，我决定我想要六个孩子。不会吧。
And yeah. Wow. So, I mean, that was sort of embedded in my head, that that was my magical number. And that's what I wanted to do with my life. And I couldn't wait to be a mom and have my first baby. And I had my first baby. I got pregnant when I was 22. Yeah.
真的。哇。所以，我的意思是，那就像是深深植入我脑海里的一个数字，那就是我的幸运数字。那就是我想在生活中做的事情。我迫不及待地想当妈妈，拥有我的第一个宝宝。然后我有了第一个宝宝。我22岁时怀孕了。对。
And I met Robert Kardashian when I was 17. How and where? Is it a meat cute? We met at the racetrack in Del Mar. No way. Wow. Yeah. And I wasn't old enough to bet.
我在17岁时遇到了罗伯特·卡戴珊。怎么认识的，在哪里？是一见钟情吗？我们在德尔玛赛马场认识的。不会吧。哇。对。而且我当时还没到可以下注的年龄。
So I had to stand to the side while my girlfriend's mom placed our bets for like $2. And I was going to, I was so excited and I was all dressed up. And I was standing there. And he came up to me and said, you know, what's your name? And I told him. And he was a little cheeky. And I was really annoyed. Like, you're a stranger.
所以我只能站在一边，看着我女友的妈妈帮我们下注，大概2美元。我当时打算，我兴奋极了，还盛装打扮了一番。我正站在那儿。他向我走来，问我，你知道的，你叫什么名字？我告诉了他。而且他有点调皮。我当时真的很生气。心想，你是个陌生人。
Go away. And, you know, the world was a much different place. You trusted people. But there was also no way to contact somebody unless you had their phone number and you were standing by your phone in the kitchen to receive the phone call. And blah, blah, blah. I mean, it was a weird world. The best times of my life.
走开。而且，你知道的，那时的世界大不相同。你会信任别人。但当时也没有任何方法可以联系到某人，除非你有他们的电话号码，而且你得站在厨房的电话机旁接听电话，等等等等。我的意思是，那是一个奇怪的世界。我一生中最美好的时光。
You couldn't snap one another, you mean? No. There was no internet, no phone, no cell phones, no computer, no iPod, none of it, no technology. Right. And so he asked me for my name. and I gave it to him, and he asked me for my number, and I didn't give it to him. But his best friend, this girl, worked at the phone company.
你是说你们不能互相发快照（Snap）吗？没有。那时没有互联网，没有电话，没有手机，没有电脑，什么都没有，没有技术。对。所以他问我的名字，我告诉了他，他问我要电话号码，我没给他。但是他的好朋友，一个女孩，在电话公司工作。
I knew you were going to say that. Every story from back then had to be like, I knew somebody at the phone company. That's the only way. Right. And they looked at my name, and there was my phone number. I mean, listen, every year. It's kind of a romantic sort of like, he just stuck with it.
我就知道你要这么说。那个年代的每个故事都得是这样的：我在电话公司有人。那是唯一的办法。对。他们查了我的名字，然后就找到了我的电话号码。我是说，听着，每年。这其实挺浪漫的，就像是，他就是死缠烂打。
Yeah, I love that. Stalker romantic. But wait, I want to get back to the racetrack. So wait, you like, I've been there a couple of times. It's a very unique environment, any racetrack. It's so kind of fun. Did you know what you were doing or we just like, oh, that's a fun name.
对，我喜欢这样。像跟踪狂一样浪漫。等等，我想回到赛马场。所以等等，你喜欢，我去过几次。那是一个非常独特的环境，任何赛马场都是。真的挺有趣的。你知道自己在做什么吗，还是我们只是觉得，哦，那个名字挺好听的。
Let's pick that horse. Well, no. I had no idea what I was doing. You weren't watching them warm up. No idea. You didn't know what horses were good muckers. Well, we walked around looking like we knew what we were doing, but we were just, you know, probably. You know, it's so visual.
我们就选那匹马吧。哦，不。我根本不知道自己在做什么。你当时没有看它们热身吗？完全不知道。你根本不知道哪匹马比较厉害。好吧，我们四处走动，看起来好像知道自己在做什么，但我们只是，你知道的，可能吧。你知道，这画面感太强了。
Like going to the racetrack in the same. 70s was like the hats and the suits and the beauty and the horses and everyone's got a cocktail and I mean it was very grown up still kind of is right at the like Kentucky Derby still like a big glamorous thing have you ever been there it was California's contos I have been once with Kim and we were we went we went to the races we were supposed to go out afterwards with a bunch of people and have a you know to the party that they give afterwards and I was drinking these things called a mint julep in a little 10 cup and i kim and i had kim didn't even drink in those days she still doesn't really drink but i did yeah and i had too many and i said
就像70年代去赛马场一样，有帽子、西装、美女、骏马，每个人都拿着一杯鸡尾酒，我的意思是，这非常成熟，现在某种程度上依然是这样，对吧，比如肯塔基德比依然是一件非常迷人的事情，你从来没去过吗？那是加州的康托斯，我去过一次，跟金一起去的，我们去了赛马场，本打算赛后和一群人一起出去，去参加他们赛后举办的派对，我当时在用一个小锡杯喝一种叫薄荷朱利p（mint julep）的东西，我和金——金当时甚至不喝酒，她现在其实也还是不太喝酒——但我喝了，对，我喝了太多，然后我说，我得去睡觉了，我太累了，我做不到这个，它们太好喝了，我想我还记得那些东西，对，所以我就去睡觉了。你去过吗，杰比，你去过吗？我从来没去过肯塔基德比，没有，但我，我曾经遇到过一杯薄荷朱利p，我必须得说，我真的被它迷住了，我想回到电话公司那个时代，不，你没法联系任何人，还有那时候德尔玛的魔力。当时每个人不是无时无刻不在联系彼此的。你可以去参加那样的事。而且不会被你的现实生活打扰。你就在那里。你在你所在的地方。我真的被这个想法迷住了。那时甚至连答录机都没有。真的没有。我的意思是，当时没有答录机。要么得在家，要么不在。对。而且，你知道的，并没有。你知道的，并没有任何，我的意思是，我觉得当时没有什么像《今夜娱乐》那样的节目，或者任何那种类型的节目。
i got to go to bed i'm too tired i can't do this they're too tasty i think i remember those things yeah so i just went to sleep did you go jb did you go i've never been to the to the kentucky derby no but i i've i met a mint julep once i got to say i'm i'm going to really taken with, I want to go back to the phone company and the time of, no, you couldn't get in touch with anybody, and the magic of Delmar back then. And everybody wasn't in touch with each other all the time. And you could go and do something like that. And you weren't bothered by your other life. You were just there. You were where you were. And I'm really taken with that idea. There weren't even answering machines back then. Not really. I mean, there was no answering machine. Either how to be home or not. Yeah. And it was, you know, there wasn't. You know, there wasn't. any kind of, I mean, I don't think there was a show like Entertainment Tonight or any of the, you know, the shows like that.
而且德尔玛赛马场听起来太迷人了。我妈妈以前经常去。当我还是个小女孩的时候，我常常看着妈妈穿着漂亮的裙子、戴着大帽子走出家门，和她的朋友们一起去。当她是单身的时候，或者当她遇到我的继父时，就和我的继父一起去，我们要去赛马。这听起来太像了，什么？你要去看赛马，而你以前只在电影里看过赛马。对，是的，是的，是的。
And the Delmar races sounded so glamorous. And my mom used to go. And I used to watch my mom when I was a little girl walk out the door and her beautiful dress and her big hat going with her friends. And when she was single or when she met my stepdad, going with my stepdad, and we're going to the races. and it sounded so like, what? You're going to the horse races, and you only saw horse races in the movies. Right, yeah, yeah, yeah.
就像，你会看到那样的一个场景，而我，就像是要去参加这么迷人的事情。我会和妈妈一起去杂货店，我们会去购物，在她结账之后，在我们结账之后，她会在这个柜台停下来，买赛车、赛马的彩票，然后回家看比赛，看看她的号码有没有中。对，而我想，我们甚至连花生酱都快买不起了，
Like, you would see a scene like that, and I was, like, going to this glamorous thing. I would go to the grocery store with my mom, and we'd go shopping, and after she checked out, after we checked out, she would stop at this counter and buy race car, our racehorse tickets to then go watch at home to see if her number win. Yeah, and I'm like, we could barely afford peanut butter,
而她却在买……你知道的，在出门的路上赌博。对。然后我们在家里观看赛马。赛马。我不知道你还能这样。所以她总是密切关注着那些马。对。
and she's, like, buying... you know, gambling on the way out of the door. Right. And then we've watched the race tracks, race things in home. Races. I didn't know you could do that. So she always kept an eye on the horses. Yeah.
你们买过彩票吗？你们买过超级百万（Mega Millions）吗？我买过几次。对，就是，赌博这事，我以前觉得赌博挺好玩、挺有意思的。我现在不玩了，但它确实是。它依然是那种某种程度上依然存在的……对，对，肖恩，你刚去了维加斯，对吧？肖恩很喜欢，但我得这么说。
Do you guys ever do, do you guys ever do the lotto? Like, do you go for the mega millions? A couple of times I've done it. Yeah, there is, I mean, gambling is, I used to have a bit of a fun, fun time with gambling. I no longer do, but it is. It's still something that sort of like lives a little bit. Yeah, yeah, Shawnee, you just went to Vegas, right? Sean loves it, but I will say this.
我的一个朋友最近对我说，我很喜欢这个想法。他说，对，我买，你知道的，当超级百万或别的什么奖金达到十亿美元左右时，我最后都会买上几张彩票。我说，真的吗？他看起来是最不可能这么做的人。我的死党克莱，我说，真的吗，你买那种彩票？他说，对，你知道我为什么买吗？我买它是为了买完之后的头五分钟，
A friend of mine said to me recently, I love this idea. He said, yeah, I buy, you know, when the mega, or whatever it is hits like a billion dollars, it's like, I end up buying a couple tickets. I said, really, he seemed like the most unlikely. My buddy Clay, and I go, really, you buy that lot of ticket? And he goes, yeah, you know why I buy it? I buy it for that five minutes after I've bought it,
我在车里的时候。对。那种感觉，那种感觉和中奖一样好。我会做些什么？仅仅是得到那种感觉。这只关乎那种感觉。没错。
and I'm in the car. Yeah. And that feeling, that feeling is just as, good as winning. What would I do? Just getting that feeling. It's only about the feeling. That's right.
因为金钱之类的东西当然重要。但我们追求的是那种感觉。他说，我很享受那种感觉。我就觉得，这挺好的。我觉得好笑的是，人们会，比如说，我觉得好笑的是，有人排队一整条街去买一张十亿美元的彩票，却不买一张五千万美元的彩票。
Because the money and whatever is sure. But it's the feeling that we're after. He's like, I enjoy that feeling. And I was like, that's good. I think it's funny that people go, like, I think it's funny that there's people that line up the street to buy a billion dollar lottery ticket, but not a $50 million dollar ticket.
好像那还不够多似的。奖金不到五千万我可不中。你知道我的意思吗？五千万？不。我要等到它涨到十亿美元。我不是刚在哪儿读到过，
Like that's not enough. I'm not going to win up for 50. Do you know what I mean? 50? No. I'll wait until it gets to a billion. Doesn't I just read somewhere that. AI now can really help your number picking.
现在人工智能真的可以帮你选号吗？别开玩了。真的。你可以上一些这种AI工具，然后说，把这周末能中彩票的号码给我。显然，它们实际上会给你提供一些非常接近的号码。哇。好吧，如果奖金是十亿美元，我的意思是，你可以中，你知道的，一亿。那就行了。
Stop. Yeah. You can go on some of these AI things and say, give me the numbers that are going to win the lottery this weekend. And they'll actually give you some that get pretty close, apparently. Wow. Well, if it's a billion dollars, I mean, you could win, you know, 100 million. That'll do it.
那就行了。只要两个。只要两个数字。现在，说到你妈妈和你的继父，你的继父，你知道的，很快就意识到这可不是什么尖端的硬核新闻，我想，我的继父是个商人，也许吧？不，我继父实际上，他做过两份生意。我继父，我叔叔有一家汽车行，而我继父会有一个工具包，他会去汽车行给汽车贴条纹。有人这么干吗？
That'll do it. Just two. Just two numbers. Now, talking about your mom and your stepdad, Was your stepdad, you know, realize very quickly this is not hard hidden journalism here, I think I, a stepdad was a businessman, perhaps? No, my stepdad was actually, he had two businesses. My stepdad, my uncle had a car dealership, and my stepdad would have a kit, and he would go to the car dealership and stripe the cars. Do anybody?
给我加点亮点？对，给我加很多。你拿那种，就像是胶带一样。就像细条纹（pinstripe）或者别的什么。对，就像细条纹。你在几个小时内就能给一辆车贴好细条纹。在那年代，那是用一种非常细的胶带完成的。我爸爸是圣迭戈最顶级的汽车胶带工。
Give me a little bit of a flare? Yeah, give me a like a lot. You take like, it's like a tape. Like a pinstripe or something. Yeah, like a pinstripe. You pinstriped a car in a couple of hours. And in those days it was done with a very thin tape. And my dad was San Diego's premier tape car tape.
那只是车上的一条胶带吗？对。而且它不会掉下来吗？对，就像《警界双雄》（Starsky & Hutch）那样。我有一辆。就像上面那个巨大的耐克钩子标志一样。完全正确。25年前我的旧雪佛兰太浩（Chevy Tahoe）上就有一个
And it would it just be a piece of tape on the car? Yeah. And it wouldn't just come off? Yeah, like Star Ski and Huts. I had one. Like that big Nike swoosh on it. Exactly. I had one of my old Chevy Tahoe 25 years ago
因为它自带一条细橙色条纹，我不喜欢。所以我去找了一个人，他在上面贴了一层细蓝色条纹。没错。这就带来了完全不同的效果。就是这么回事。我知道你在雪佛兰上瞎折腾什么。我的意思是，你应该买GMC的。这是GMC出现之前的事。
because it came with a thin orange and I didn't like it. So I went to a guy and he put a thin blue over it. That's right. And it just made all the difference. That's the same thing. I know what you're doing messing around with Chevy. I mean, that's you should have been a GMC. This is pre-GMC.
你当年不喜欢专业级别的车吗？我喜欢。我喜欢专业级别的。我喜欢通用汽车家族的一切。所以他做过那个。然后他也是一个拥有公司的家伙，那家公司负责在屋顶上装天线。好吧。但他实际上是自己去干。
Did you not like professional grade back then? I do. I love professional grade. I love everything in the GM family. So he did that. And then he also was a guy who had a company that put antennas on the roof. Okay. But he actually did it.
就像他有几个手下给他打工。所以如果你买了一台电视，我记得我们买的第一台彩色电视。然后他会开一家公司，你知道的，做广告然后上门服务。对。把天线装在你的屋顶上。屋顶上的兔耳天线。对。对。
Like he had a few guys that work for him. So if you bought a TV, I remember we got our first colored TV. And then he would have a company that, you know, advertised and came out. Right. And put your antenna on your roof. The rabbit ears up on the roof. Yeah. Yeah.
就像他手下有几个人。所以如果你买了一台电视，我记得我们买的第一台是彩色电视。然后他会找一家公司，你知道的，打广告并上门服务。对吧。把天线装在你的屋顶上。屋顶上的兔耳天线。对啊。对啊。
I got you. So, but my question behind the question is where was. So I guess he was a business. Right. He made money. Did that start to, how early did the business interest in you get sparked? That entrepreneurial sort of creative. kind of what could I get into next kind of thing?
我明白。所以，我真正想问的是，他的业务在哪里。所以我想他是个商人。对吧。他赚了钱。那是在什么时候开始的？你对商业的兴趣是从多大开始被激发的？那种创业的、富有创造力的，接下来我能涉足什么领域的这种想法？
Oh, that came from my grandmother and my mother. So my grandmother and my mother both had their own stores in La Jolla, California. Right. And I grew up in San Diego and then La Jolla. And my mom still lives there to this day. She's almost 92. But she had, her last store that she had was a children's store 45 years, called Shannon and Company. Her last name is Shannon.
哦，那是由我外祖母和母亲带给我的。我外祖母和母亲在加利福尼亚州拉霍亚都有自己的店铺。没错。我在圣迭戈长大，然后搬到拉霍亚。我妈妈直到今天还住在那里。她快92岁了。她开过的最后一家店是一家开了45年的童装店，名叫香农公司（Shannon and Company）。她的姓氏是香农。
Yeah. And my grandmother had a candle store called the Candles of La Jolla. So basically when I was 12 years old, instead of going to the La Jolla Shores to learn how to surf with all my friends, I was going to my grandmother's candle store and working, and the first job I had, I was the gift wrapper. So my grandmother taught me, it was the best. And by the way, I'm the best gift wrapper. Are you really?
是的。我外祖母开了一家名为“拉霍亚蜡烛”的蜡烛店。基本上在我12岁的时候，我没有像所有朋友那样去拉霍亚海岸学冲浪，而是去我外祖母的蜡烛店工作。我的第一份工作是包装礼品。所以我外祖母教我的，真的是太棒了。顺便说一句，我是最棒的礼品包装师。真的吗？
Yeah. Ever. I like it. I watch those videos. of the Japanese people. I saw that too. Yeah, and I'm like, I'm trying to emulate. I'm the worst.
对啊。有史以来最厉害的。我喜欢。我看过那些日本人的视频。我也看过那个。是的，我就想，我正在努力效仿。我是最差的。
At Christmas, I realized I'm the worst. I love it. Wait, so, Chris, do you have, like, incredible techniques about, like, hiding edges and curling seams? Yes. Yes. Oh, and I do, like, one day, I learned how to use the ribbon maker,
到圣诞节时，我发现我是最差的。我太喜欢了。等等，克里斯，你有什么了不起的技巧吗，比如隐藏边缘和卷曲接缝？有的，有的。哦，而且我，有一回，我学会了如何使用制带机，
the bow maker machine. So I got really good at bows. And so I have these hidden talents. Like, they say we have no talent. Oh, I've got talent. Yeah. You have some great gift wrapping talent. Do you have a wrapping room at the house?
那个制作蝴蝶结的机器。所以我很擅长做蝴蝶结。因此我有一些隐藏的技能。就像他们说我们没有天赋一样。哦，我很有天赋。是的。你有一些出色的礼品包装天赋。你家里有一个包装间吗？
I do. I do. The gift wrap room. I have a friend that has a wrapping room. With rolls of wrapping paper and drawers of tissue and it's very exciting. Chris, can you look at a gift or something you want to wrap? And can you just eyeball it and go? I know exactly how much paper I need for that. I used to a little bit better.
有的，有的。礼品包装间。我有个朋友有一个包装间。里面有卷装的包装纸、一抽屉一抽屉的面巾纸，非常令人兴奋。克里斯，你能看着一件礼物或你想包装的东西，然后目测一下就说出来吗？我确切知道那需要多少纸。我以前稍微更擅长一点。
Now I've, you know, if I really get confused over a gift, I just sell-a-fane it. and put a bow on it. Call it a day. And it's so cute. Telephan will help you avoid those terrible paper cuts. That's right. Paper cuts you can get from wrapping gifts. That's right.
现在呢，你知道的，如果我对一件礼物实在感到棘手，我就直接用玻璃纸把它包起来，然后系个蝴蝶结。今天就到这里。而且非常可爱。玻璃纸能帮你避免那些可怕的纸划伤。没错。包装礼物时可能会遇到的纸划伤。没错。
Yeah, yeah, yeah. But I love those, I love those videos from Japan. I know. They're so fabulous. And like, yeah, OCD. So wait, Chris, so after the, after you, so you learned some business while you were rapping, you're like, wait, how did that work? And how did that kind of.
对，对，对。不过我喜欢那些来自日本的视频。我知道。它们太棒了。而且，是的，强迫症。所以等等，克里斯，那么在……在你之后，所以你在包装时学到了一些商业知识，你就在想，等等，那是怎么运作的？它是怎么样的……
Well, your mom and your grandma were a great business inspiration for you. Right. So I think, listen, when you're young and you see my mother at the time was a single mom, and my grandmother and my grandfather lived across the street, and my grandmother helped raise me. So when you see the two most important people in your life at the time, my grandmother and my mom, get up and get dressed to the nines and go to work every day and get there at nine o'clock and have a routine and have a business and pay the bills. And they were so proud of their businesses and how they ran them.
好吧，你妈妈和外祖母为你提供了很好的商业灵感。对吧。所以我觉得，听着，当你年轻的时候，你看到我妈妈当时是一个单亲妈妈，我的外祖母和外祖父住在街对面，我外祖母帮着抚养我。所以当你看到你生命中当时最重要的两个人，我的外祖母和我妈妈，盛装打扮，每天去上班，九点钟准时到达，生活有规律，经营着自己的生意，支付账单。而且她们为自己的生意以及如何经营它们感到无比骄傲。
I worked for both of them on and off. And I learned a lot in those days. I finally graduated to being on the floor with customers. Then I graduated to the cash register. And I just learned a lot. Those were some of the best learning years of my life because I learned so much about. And then from there, I became a stewardess for American Airlines. And I was a flight attendant.
我断断续续地为她们俩工作过。我在那段日子里学到了很多。我最终升级为可以在店里直接面对顾客。然后我晋升到了收银台。我学到了很多东西。那是我一生中最宝贵的学习岁月之一，因为我学到了太多。从那以后，我成了美国航空公司的空中小姐。我曾是一名空乘人员。
And when I was a flight attendant, that gave me great social intelligence, social skills. I didn't know you were a flight attendant. Learning how to run a team. Yeah. And just like some really interesting things that were very valuable at a very young age. My mom did that for like 30 years of Pan Amp. She did? Yeah.
当我还是个空乘时，这赋予了我极高的社会智能和社交技能。我不知道你当过空乘。学会如何管理团队。是的，还有一些在很年轻时就极具价值的真正有趣的事情。我妈妈在泛美航空干了大约30年。她干过？是的。
It was the coolest thing for me as a kid just flying around the world kind of, you know, in the back with my little suit on, you know, because I had to dress up for the free tickets. Yeah. You still fly Pan Am. don't you, Jay? Yeah, they keep getting canceled these fights. He still fits in that suit. You guys.
对我还是个孩子的时候来说，能飞遍世界各地，穿着我的小套装坐在后舱，那是最酷的事，你知道的，因为免费机票我必须盛装打扮。是的。你还在坐泛美航空吧，杰？对，这些航班总是被取消。他还能穿进那套西装。你们这些人。
It sounds like, yeah, you know, the thing is, at the heart of it is like this, you've had this consistent work ethic. I've learned, yeah. That's super strong. I'm really proud of what they taught me and what I was able to absorb. But then even more importantly, how I raised my kids and what they were able to learn from the whole experience and how they were raised and how they, it was always,
听起来，是的，你知道，核心在于，你一直保持着这种始终如一的职业道德。我学到了，是的。这非常坚定。我为他们教给我的东西以及我能够吸收的东西感到非常骄傲。但更重要的是，我是如何抚养我的孩子的，他们从整个经历中以及他们是如何被抚养的、他们是如何……这总是……
my kids joke and they say to me, you know, mom, during the summer, or they'll tell a story and they'll go, my mom during the summer, when we were in, you know, it's supposed to be on vacation, my mom, you know, in the old days, the 90s or the 80s, we used to have a landline. And on the landline, as we became more successful and had more opportunities, the stuff in the house got better.
我的孩子们开玩笑对我说，你知道，妈妈，在夏天，或者他们会讲个故事，然后说，我妈妈在夏天的时候，当我们在，你知道的，本该在度假的时候，我妈妈，你知道的，在过去的日子里，90年代或80年代，我们曾有一部固定电话。随着我们变得越来越成功、拥有更多机会，那部固定电话在家里也变得越来越好。
The TVs got bigger. The phones got more complicated. And we set this intercom system on the phone. So you have a big land phone, landline phone, sitting next to all these counters and all the buttons. And there was a thing. And Chloe always tells the story, my mom used to intercom the whole house.
电视变大了。电话变得更复杂了。我们在电话上设置了这个内部对讲系统。所以你有一个大型的固定电话，放在所有柜台和所有按钮旁边。有一个装置。克洛伊总是讲这个故事，我妈妈以前用对讲机呼叫全屋。
It's 7 a.m. Time to get up. Make your beds. And so I raised my kids like that. Like, no, no. No, we're not laying in bed. Life is happening. Get up.
早上7点了。该起床了。整理好你们的床铺。所以我就是这样抚养我的孩子的。就像，不，不。不，我们不赖在床上一动不动。生活在继续，起来。
We've got stuff to do. I love that. I love that. Me too. That's really cool. Wait, so what happened after the candle thing and working in that store? And what was like kind of the next venture for you after that? That made you want to propel further into being a businesswoman?
我们还有很多事要做。我喜欢这样。我也喜欢。太棒了。等等，那么蜡烛那档子事和在那家店工作之后发生了什么？在此之后，你的下一个创业尝试是什么？是什么让你想要进一步成为一名女商人？
I worked there. Then I worked at a boutique in La Jolla for a friend and then for my mom. And I loved having. having structure in my life. I loved having something to do and to get dressed for. And my mother and my grandmother always told me that it was so important to present myself to the world in a way that I wanted to be, like look your best, be on your best behavior. If you don't have something nice to say, don't say anything at all. You know, really good manners. Right, right. I was going to It was going to say, for me, like, I've got to believe it before I can expect anyone else to believe it.
我在那儿工作。后来我在拉霍亚的一家精品店为朋友工作，然后又为我妈妈工作。我喜欢生活中有结构。我喜欢有事情可做、有衣服可穿。我母亲和外祖母总是告诉我，以自己希望呈现的方式向世界展现自己是多么重要，比如穿得最好，表现得最得体。如果你没有什么好听的话说，那就什么也别说。你知道的，要有很好的礼貌。对，对。我本来想说，对我来说，我必须先相信它，然后才能期望别人相信它。
So you get up, get up, get out there and look like where you want to go. That's exactly right. And surround, you know, a couple things. So then I became, then I went and I applied to be a flight attendant, Sean, to answer that question. And then from there, I got married to Robert Kardashian. So that's kind of, and then I started having kids. So that's the, you know, the Breeders Digest version. Which was the real job.
所以你要振作起来，站起来，走出去，让自己看起来像是要去你想去的地方。完全正确。而且要周围，你知道，有几件事。然后我成了，然后我去申请当空乘，肖恩，来回答那个问题。从那以后，我嫁给了罗伯特·卡戴珊。所以差不多就是这样，然后我开始生孩子。这就是，你知道的，育儿文摘版本。那才是真正的职业。
Which is, yeah, you know, the kids and being a mom, that was at a very young age. But, you know, along the way, the one thing you guys can probably relate to or think about or your, you know, listeners can think about is my mother-in-law was the first one. Now it's, you know, a mantra in our house. But my mother-in-law, Nana, was always saying, Robert, you know, to her son. Robert, show me who your friends are, and I'll show you who you are. And she used to just gripe it all of us about if she thought anybody around us was shady or dishonest or a little creepy or, you know, anything off. She was, because I met her and Robert at such a young age, you know, he was 12 years older than I was.
也就是，是的，你知道，照顾孩子和当妈妈，那是在很年轻的时候。但是，你知道，在这段旅程中，你们可能会产生共鸣、会去思考的，或者你们的听众可以思考的一点是，我的婆婆是第一个这样说的人。现在这成了我们家的一句座右铭。但我的婆婆，娜娜，总是对她儿子罗伯特说。罗伯特，告诉我你的朋友是谁，我就知道你是谁。她过去常常对我们所有人唠叨，如果她觉得我们周围任何人有些可疑、不诚实、有点令人毛骨悚然，或者，你知道的，有任何不对劲的地方。她会这样，因为我遇到她和罗伯特时太年轻了，你知道，他比我大12岁。
But I just learned so much because then I had this whole Armenian family surrounding. that I'd never had a big, big family. I had one sister. And my mom was divorced for the longest time until she met my dad and then got married when I was 13. But a lot of my life, it was me, my mom, and my sister. So having this big Armenian family around me
但我学到了很多，因为当时我身边有一个亚美尼亚大家庭。我从来没有过这么大的家族。我只有一个姐姐。我妈妈单身了很长时间，直到她遇到了我爸爸，并在我13岁时结婚。但在我生命的大部分时间里，家里只有我和妈妈、姐姐。所以有这个庞大的亚美尼亚大家庭围着我
was very, it was so amazing. And some of the things I learned, I let it all soak in. I was like a sponge. I was like, I love having all these. people watching out for me because they met me so young. And they were helping me grow up. Right.
真的非常非常奇妙。我学到的一些东西，我都全盘吸收了。我就像一块海绵。我想，我喜欢有这么多人照顾我，因为他们在我很小的时候就认识我了。他们一直在帮我成长。对吧？
Right. Right. A big community. Yeah. That's so great. Was there, go ahead, Shoney. No, I was just going to say, I was just going to share one of my first jobs was at a furniture store in downtown Glen Ellen.
对的。对的。一个庞大的社群。是的。太棒了。还有，你接着说，肖尼。不，我只是想说，我想分享一下我的第一份工作是在市中心格伦埃林的一家家具店。
And I had to answer the phones. And all I did all day long was call my friend Sherry in Arizona. And then the bills would come. And their phone bill was like 100. hundreds of dollars, which was huge back then, like, probably like $1,000. It's huge now. Yeah, the guy who comes and be like, who are you calling in Arizona? I was like, that's my sister, just trying to be in touch.
我得接电话。我一整天都在给亚利桑那州的朋友雪莉打电话。然后账单就寄来了。他们的电话费好像有几百美元，这在当时是一笔巨款，大概相当于现在的1,000美元。现在看来也是巨款。对，那个来收账的人说，你在给亚利桑那州谁打电话？我说，那是我的姐姐，只是想保持联系。
But it was my best friend, and I got in someone, and then I got fired because of that. Oh, my God. That's my story. That's my story, my first job. I love that story. Yeah. I'm just trying to look on the chart where I'm going to put that. You know what?
但其实是我最好的朋友，然后我被别人发现了，结果我就被解雇了。哦，天哪。这就是我的故事。这就是我的故事，我的第一份工作。我喜欢这个故事。是的。我正在图表上找我要把它放在哪里。你知道吗？
One of my first jobs. Yeah. The things that we will do, one of my first jobs, I was really wanting to do something. I mean, this is how, I guess, I don't know, motivated I must have been to make some money. But because my mom, it wasn't like she was, you know, passing out money to buy clothes. And we were getting to the age where we really loved clothes and we wanted to buy things and we were teenagers and all of it. And so I got a job up the street from my house that I could then get. on the school bus and get to middle school or high school.
我的第一份工作之一。是的。我们做过的事情，我的第一份工作之一，我真的很想做点什么。我是说，我当时对赚钱的动力有多大，我也不知道。但因为我妈妈并不是那种会随手给你零花钱买衣服的人。我们正处于开始真正喜欢衣服、想买东西的年纪，我们是青少年，诸如此类。所以我在离家不远的一条街上找了一份工作，这样我就可以坐校车去初中或高中了。
And it was at a donut shop. And my job was to take a glaze scraper and scrape the glaze off of the floor. And they would give me a little money and some free donut holes every morning. Wow. And I was the best glaze scraper in, I think, in San Diego. Pretty sure. Sean, how lost are you in this? He's trying to figure out if it's a bad job.
那是在一家甜甜圈店。我的工作是用一把刮刀把地上的糖霜刮掉。他们每天早晨会给我一点钱和一些免费的甜甜圈球。哇。而且我是圣迭戈最好的糖霜刮手，我想是的。百分之百确定。肖恩，你在这个话题里迷失了多少？他正在琢磨这算不算是一份糟糕的工作。
He can't decide whether it's a bad job. Hey, this is a job? You guys, I'm going to ruin my makeup. I'll eat the glaze off the floor. I mean, that's incredible. I don't need the scrapers. Guys, it was amazing. Sean's volunteering for any sort of glaze scraping in any part of the room.
他拿不定主意这算不算是一份糟糕的工作。嘿，这也是工作吗？各位，我要毁容了。我会把地上的糖霜吃掉。我是说，这太不可思议了。我不需要刮刀。伙计们，这太棒了。肖恩自愿去房间的任何角落刮糖霜。
So if you ever need anybody who, like listen, these skills somehow, you know, worked for me later in life. I don't know. Go figure. Yeah. And we will be right back. And now back to the show. What would you say to these young people that are going off to business school and they're killing themselves trying to, like, top business schools and learn all the business stuff that one needs to, like, where would you, what size would you put that sort of like? the traditional business structured, you know, in today's society and climate for business success.
所以如果你需要任何这样的人，听着，这些技能不知怎么的，你知道的，对我的后半生很有帮助。谁知道呢。好吧。我们马上回来。现在回到节目中。你会对那些要去读商学院、拼死拼活想要进入顶级商学院并学习人们所需的所有商业知识的年轻人说些什么？对于商业成功，你把传统商业架构放在什么样的位置？
Wow. The nuts and the bolts of it. I'm going to get in trouble here because I did not go to college. Uh-huh. That's okay. And that wasn't important to me because I didn't, I wasn't the most amazing. Like, I didn't love school because I was social. Does that make sense?
哇。核心要点。我要惹麻烦了，因为我没有上过大学。嗯哼。没关系。这对我来说并不重要，因为我不是最出色的。我不喜欢上学，因为我喜欢社交。这说得通吗？
I love being, I love the. socialization of it. I love, I think, you know, some of my kids have been trying to decide, do we want to just do homeschool? Do we love, you know, this kind of school as the kids get older? And Kendall and Kylie, my two youngest, went to homeschool the last year of their high school years, and then they graduated. But it wasn't this, you know, it's always been for us about, or for me, about socialization and making sure that obviously I have a good education. and I know my ABCs. And, you know, I'm a smart cookie and I love to learn and I soak it all in.
我喜欢，我喜欢那种社交氛围。我想，你知道，我的一些孩子一直在纠结，我们是只想在家上学吗？随着孩子们长大，我们喜欢这种学校吗？金和凯莉，我最小的两个孩子，在高中最后一年转成了在家上学，然后她们毕业了。但对我们（或对我）来说，这从来都不是关于……而是关于社交，确保我显然接受过良好的教育，并且认识ABC字母。而且，你知道，我很聪明，我喜欢学习，并全盘吸收。
But everyone learns differently. There's so many different options. And I think that's what's interesting. And so I think the options out there are so vast. However, it really, you have to follow your heart, but it's also what do you want to go into? Some rule of thumb and thought of some parents and kids alike. and people in general is that if you get that education under your belt, then that's your safety net.
但每个人的学习方式都不同。有这么多的选择。我认为这很有趣。所以外面的选择非常广泛。然而，你必须跟随自己的内心，但这也是你想从事什么行业的问题。一些父母、孩子以及普通人的经验法则和想法是，如果你能掌握那种教育，那就是你的安全网。
Then you can go forward in your life and now you're set with your, you know, you have your tool belt on and you can go out there and do various things. And I'm not, like I love that too. My son went to USC. Kim went to college for maybe a couple weeks. And, you know, Courtney graduated from college. And, you know, half of my kids did it. it and half of my kids didn't.
然后你就可以继续前进，现在你带上了工具包，可以出去做各种各样的事情。我不，我很喜欢那样。我儿子去了南加州大学。金只上了几个星期的大学。库特尼大学毕业了。你知道的，我有一半的孩子上了大学，一半的孩子没上。
So it's a mixed bag for me, but I think it really depends on if you want to be a doctor or a physician of any kind, a surgeon, you know, medical field, attorney, lawyer. That's necessary. But I think it's just going to be what you're, you know, follow your heart. What is it that, you know, that gets you excited about life and what you want to do with your career? And start sooner than later. Yeah, you know, it's fine. I'm going through J.B.
所以对我来说情况很杂，但我认为这真的取决于你想不想成为一名医生、各种内科医生、外科医生、医疗领域人员，或者律师。这是必要的。但我认为这只取决于你的……你知道的，跟随你的内心。是什么让你对生活感到兴奋，你想在职业生涯中做什么？而且要趁早开始。是的，你知道，没关系。我正在经历J.B.
you went through it with your eldest, and I'm kind of going through it now with my teenage boys because they're at that point where they're looking at colleges and we're going to do a college tour at spring break. And I keep sort of saying to him, you know, there's a pressure not just from the parents, but you can feel it from the peer group as everybody's talking about it. So it builds up this kind of frenzy about where to go
你是和你的大孩子一起经历的，而我现在正和我的十几岁男孩们经历着，因为他们正处于考虑大学的阶段，我们打算在春假期间进行一次大学参观。我一直在对他说，你知道，压力不仅仅来自父母，你也能从同龄人群体中感受到，因为每个人都在谈论它。所以这造成了一种关于去哪里的狂热
and all the sort of stuff. And I said, look. Yeah, having to decide what you're going to do as an adult. And I go, you know what, man, any one of these places, you're pretty much guaranteed of getting a really good education. You've got to decide what you want your experience. to be, what you want your life experience to be.
以及所有这些类似的事情。我说，听着。是的，必须决定作为一个成年人你要做什么。我说，你知道吗，伙计，在这些地方中的任何一个，你基本上都能保证受到很好的教育。你必须决定你希望你的经历是什么，你希望你的人生体验是什么。
So true. Right? And don't, I urge you not to get caught up in that. And I'm really, and I think it's kind of lending because I just, I see them, I see these kids and they're getting so wrapped up in it. Yeah, life will narrow you like real quick soon anyway. Yeah. Yeah.
千真万确。对吧？不要，我敦促你们不要卷入其中。而且我真的，我认为这很有帮助，因为我看到他们，我看到这些孩子们被深深地卷入其中。是的，无论如何，生活很快就会让你缩小选择范围。是的。是的。
You know, Jay, B, you go to college. I dropped out, I dropped out of college after one semester because I was like, you did? Yeah. For me, I went, you know what? I looked around at all my peers and my friends and kids I grew up with, and I said, this is not where I'm going. I want to go over here, and I want to jump into life, and I moved to New York at age 20.
你知道，J.B，你上了大学。我退学了，我在一个学期后就从大学退学了，因为我想……你退了？是的。对我来说，我当时想，你知道吗？我环顾了我所有的同龄人、朋友和我一起长大的孩子，我说，这不是我要去的地方。我想去那边，我想跃入生活，我在20岁时搬到了纽约。
But what it did for me, I went for four years and never graduated, but still got a doctorate. But anyway. That up boy. Wait, we want the recipe for that. From the furniture store? Yeah. No, but what it did for me was what it does for a lot of kids is it gets you out of the house.
但它为我做的是，我上了四年学却从未毕业，但还是拿到了博士学位。但无论如何。好样的，小伙子。等等，我们想要那个秘方。从家具店来的？没有，但它为我做的事，也是它为许多孩子做的事，就是把你带出家门。
That's it. And you get out of the house and you're with your peers in a totally different setting and you find out who you are. Neo-Nor horizons. New horizons. And yes, academics aside, socially what it did for me was I was like,
就是这样。你离开了家，在完全不同的环境中和同龄人在一起，你发现了你是谁。开辟新视野。新视野。是的，抛开学术不谈，它在社交上为我做的是，我当时觉得，
oh, I found my people. And I found- Johnny, you know what's funny about that. Like, J.B., you were working as a young kid. You were already working as an actress. So you were already sort of socializing, and you were already doing that. You were out of the house, in effect.
哦，我找到了我的人群。我找到了——强尼，关于这一点，有趣的是。就像，J.B.，你很小的时候就在工作了。你当时就已经在做演员了。所以你其实已经在社交了，你已经在那样做了。实际上，你已经不在家了。
With your peers. I had gone to boarding school at age 12. So I was already out. Like I'd already gone, you know what I mean? Yeah, that was like an early college boarding school. Yeah, yeah. I should have studied something to fall back on. See, I think that's important to note, though.
和同龄人在一起。我12岁就去寄宿学校了。所以我已经离开了。就像我已经去过了，你知道我的意思吗？是的，那就像是一个早期的大学寄宿学校。是的，是的。我应该学点东西留作退路。你看，我认为这一点很重要。
I think that everyone, and I really believe that everybody needs structure and a purpose. That's what it is. And a community and socialization. All of that, I love about school. And if you're not ready, to jump off the diving board into the pool with no water in it, so to speak,
我觉得每个人，我是说我真的坚信每个人都需要结构和目标。就是这样。还有社区和社交。所有这些，我都喜欢学校的地方。如果你还没有准备好，可以说是从跳板上跳进一个没有水的游泳池里，
because you don't know what you're going to do. And that's probably a great decision because then you'll figure it out. Yeah, because I went to college knowing I was going to study music. That's it. So I had a purpose. But you're right, you're right, Chris,
因为你不知道你要做什么。这可能是一个极好的决定，因为这样你就能摸索出来了。是的，因为我去上大学时就知道我要学音乐。就是这样。所以我有一个目标。但你是对的，克里斯，你说得对，
about what you said is like, if you don't, I love that. If you're diving into a pool with no water, there's no reason. No, and Sean, the music that you studied, it did help you. It has been a big part of what you do. Well, yeah, no, but continuing on,
关于你所说的那种，如果你不，我很喜欢那个。如果你跳进一个没有水的游泳池，那就没有理由了。不，肖恩，你学的音乐确实对你有帮助。它一直是你所做事情的很大一部分。嗯，对，不，但接着说，
and, like, you wouldn't have done Good Night Oscar. All of that, the Tabasco. What a show. This is a program. But had you not done that, you wouldn't have had the skill to do that, right? Totally. One thing leads to another.
而且，比如，你不会演《晚安，奥斯卡》。所有这些，塔巴斯科。多么精彩的节目。这是一个节目。但如果你没做过那些，你就不会有做这件事的技能，对吧？完全正确。一环扣一环。
But I'm lucky, like, we're all lucky, the four of us talking right now, and there's many people that we know that are lucky, that if you know, if you have a passion inside of you, early on as a kid and you know what you love to do, the earlier you know what to be, the earlier you know what you love to do,
但我很幸运，就像我们一样，我们都很幸运，我们现在的四个人在聊天，还有很多我们认识的人都很幸运，如果你知道，如果你内心有一种激情，很小的时候就作为一个孩子，你知道你热爱做什么，你越早知道自己要成为什么样的人，你越早知道你热爱做什么，
the more success you're likely to have later. A thousand percent. And it's like Jason said, he had a direction. Like he knew that's what he wanted to do. So why I'm over here with, you know, all my energy needs to go to my dream. And in order to accomplish my dreams, it needs incredible focus and dedication to this.
你以后取得成功的可能性就越大。百分之一千。就像杰森说的，他有方向。就像他知道那就是他想做的事。所以我这边，你知道，我所有的能量都得投入到我的梦想中。为了实现我的梦想，这需要对这件事有极大的专注和奉献。
It doesn't mean you're, you know, sitting at home. playing video games, doing nothing. No, and you need to pay the rent too, right, J.B.? I mean, for real. Yeah, yeah, yeah. You got to keep the lights on. So, wait, so Chris, so then talk to me about keeping up with the Kardashians.
这并不意味着你，你知道，坐在家里。玩电子游戏，什么也不做。不，你还得付房租，对吧，J.B.？我是说，说真的。对，对，对。你得维持生计。所以，等等，克里斯，那跟我聊聊《与卡戴珊同行》吧？
Like, how did it start? What did it do for you? Were you apprehensive about doing it? Because you're like, oh, my God, there's cameras. Like, what? And what was your perception of beginning the show and when did it start to change? Yeah, and did this start?
比如，它是怎么开始的？它对你有什么影响？你当时对做这个节目感到担忧吗？因为你会想，哦，天哪，有摄像机。比如，什么？你对开始这个节目最初的看法是什么？它是什么时候开始改变的？是的，这个是从哪里开始的？
Does this story write where, Ryan Seacrest started talking to you about this, perhaps, and on the heels of the Osbournes getting a lot of traction. And is the timing right? Do I have that right? No. Right. So I think a lot of people talk to me and a couple of my older kids from time to time.
这个故事写的是，瑞安·西克雷斯特开始跟你谈论这个，也许是在奥斯本一家获得很大关注之后。时机对吗？我没记错吧？不。对。所以我想很多人时不时地会和我以及我的几个大孩子谈论这件事。
But always, I mean, for years had said to me, you're a family, you've got to do a reality show. Nobody would believe what goes on in this. It's his life of years. Today's Brady Bunch. And it was just, you couldn't make any of it up. And so I eventually decided to create this show in my mind, and it kind of lived up there for a while.
但一直以来，我是说，多年来一直对我说，你们是一个家庭，你们得拍一个真人秀。没有人会相信这里面发生了什么。这是他多年的生活。今天的《布雷迪部族》。这简直是，你根本编不出这些。所以我最终决定在脑海里构思这个节目，它在那里停留了一段时间。
And then I remember we had been approached by a company years ago, and they thought it was a good idea. and my best friend was living in New York, and she was doing a talk show, Kathy Lee Gifford and Kathy would go, you guys, you know, she was Kendall and Kylie's godmother, and she would, you know, when they were born, and she would always go, oh, my God, you guys are wild,
然后我记得多年前有一家公司来找过我们，他们觉得这是个好主意。我最好的朋友当时住在纽约，她在做一档脱口秀节目，凯茜·李·吉福德，凯茜总是说，你们这些家伙，你知道，她是肯德尔和凯莉的教母，凯茜会，你知道，在她们出生时，她总是说，哦，天哪，你们太疯狂了，
you know, this is crazy, and she'd come visit and think, people have got to see what's going on. And I just thought it was normal. You know, I thought I'm living the life. And one night, This girl, Dina Katz, came over to my house, and she's the casting director for many shows amongst them
你知道，这太疯狂了，她会来串门，觉得人们必须看看这里发生了什么。而我只觉得这很正常。你知道，我以为我过着这样的生活。有一天，这个女孩，迪娜·卡茨，来到我家，她是很多节目的选角导演，其中包括
dancing with the stars and things like that. And she's close friends with Ryan Seacrest. So she came over, and she couldn't believe what was happening in my house on like a Tuesday. Wait, what's going on over there? For spaghetti. What was going on over there? I mean, just the people that would call or stop by,
《与星共舞》之类的节目。而且她和瑞安·西克雷斯特是密友。所以她过来了，简直不敢相信周二的时候我家里会发生这种事。等等，那边在干什么？为了意大利面。那边在干什么？我是说，光是那些打电话来或顺道拜访的人，
just a lot of, you know, celebrity interaction and drama and just wild. It was just extraordinary. And she would listen to my life and think it was wild. So she said, I'm going to present this to Ryan Seacrest. So the next day I spoke to Ryan's team and went in for a meeting a couple days later.
就有大量，你知道的名人互动、戏剧性事件，而且简直太疯狂了。这简直太不寻常了。她听了我的生活，觉得这很疯狂。所以她说，我要把这个呈献给瑞安·西克雷斯特。所以第二天我跟瑞安的团队谈了，几天后去开了一个会。
They had just signed a production deal with E, NBC Comcast. And they then, you know, Ryan presented it to the network. They picked it up, and 30 days later, we were shooting Keeping Up with the Kardashians. Wow. So it happened really fast. What was the conversation like with the kids? Like, did it take, do you have to twist any arms or were they excited about the idea?
他们刚刚跟E!频道、NBC环球签了一笔制作协议。然后他们，你知道，瑞安把它呈献给了电视网。他们买下了它，30天后，我们就在拍摄《与卡戴珊同行》了。哇。所以进展真的很快。跟孩子们的谈话是怎么进行的？比如，花了，你得说服他们吗，还是他们对这个想法很兴奋？
Listen, at that point, and I mean, to this day, I'm still at the, I'm still their manager, but at the time, I was nobody's manager. I was, Courtney and I were working in our clothing store called, I'm. a smooch and the girls had a store called Dash nearby in Calabasas. And it was, I just said, family, I have this opportunity and this is what I want us to do. And everybody said, okay, you know, I'm not going to lie, Courtney, kind of looked at me sideways like mom. And I'm like, Courtney, we can sell more T-shirts. Imagine. This shows in, you know, it's a global network. It'll air in 200 countries. Why not? You know, I saw an opportunity.
听着，在那个时候，我的意思是，直到今天，我仍然在，我仍然是他们的经纪人，但在当时，我不是任何人的经纪人。我和考特尼在我们的服装店工作，店名叫，我。一家叫“香吻”的店，女孩们在卡abasas附近有一家叫Dash的店。当时，我只是说，家人们，我有这个机会，这就是我想让我们做的事。每个人都说，好吧，你知道，我不会撒谎，考特尼斜眼看着我，就像看着妈妈一样。我说，考特尼，我们可以卖更多的T恤。想象一下。这个节目在，你知道，它是一个全球电视网。它将在200个国家播出。为什么不呢？你知道，我看到了一个机会，
and it was just something that I wanted to do because it was also going to help me keep the lights on if I'm being honest. It was like an income. And Kendall and Kylie were 9 and 10. Kylie was 9 years old. That's amazing. Kendall was 10.
这只是我想做的事，因为说实话，这也将帮我维持生计。这就像是一笔收入。当时肯德尔和凯莉9岁和10岁。凯莉才9岁。太惊人了。肯德尔10岁。
And I told them what was happening. And I said, guys, you don't have to be on the show. But if you want to come and be a part of it, you can film on the weekends or holidays or after school or, you know, whenever it's appropriate. And that's kind of how it got started. And that was, we started filming, I think, 2000, maybe six.
我把发生的事告诉了她们。我说，伙计们，你们不必参加这个节目。但如果你们想来成为其中的一部分，你们可以在周末、假期、放学后，或者，你知道，在任何合适的时候进行拍摄。事情差不多就是这样开始的。那是，我们开始拍摄，我想，2000，可能是六年。
It aired in 2007. And right now, we work for Disney. We're filming the Kardashians. And this is season 28. Wow. So what was the ask? Like, how did you present this to them? Like, was it, well, the cameras are only going to be here
它在2007年播出。现在，我们为迪士尼工作。我们在拍摄《卡戴珊家族》。这是第28季。哇。所以要求是什么？比如，你是怎么向她们提出这个要求的？比如，是，摄像机只会在这里
for like an hour a day or they're going to be constantly set up or they're going to be fixed cameras. won't be any camera operator, so you won't really know, like, how is it, how does it, how did it start then versus how is it now? And what were the expectations as far as their, their role would be? Right. Well, they, we all fell into it like a fish in water. It was quite extraordinary. And you can't do something. Listen, I can create something and I can produce something, but you can't control other people, even though they're your kids. I mean, I have a great deal of love and respect for my children,
比如一天一小时，还是会一直架设，还是会安装固定摄像机？不会有摄像师，所以你们不会真正知道，比如，情况是怎样的，它是怎么开始的，现在又如何？在她们的角色方面有什么期望吗？对。嗯，我们所有人都像鱼儿得水一样投入进去了。这相当不寻常。你没法做一件事。听着，我可以创造一些东西，我也可以制作一些东西，但你无法控制别人，即使他们是你的孩子。我是说，我对我的孩子们有着极大的爱和尊重，
and I'm never going to make them do something that they don't want to do. But it was, I was in heaven because everybody, a crew shows up. We started with one crew. So it's like maybe three cameras, two cameras and sound. Do they come in like 7 a.m.? We started very, very early in glam. at seven, but the first season, we literally were filming seven or eight days a week and about 18 hours a day.
而且我绝不会强迫他们去做他们不想做的事。但当时，我简直身在天堂，因为每个人，一个剧组出现了。我们从一个剧组开始。所以大概是三台摄像机，两台摄像机和录音。他们是早上7点左右来吗？我们很早就开始化妆了。7点，但第一季，我们真的每周拍摄七到八天，每天大约18个小时。
I'm not exaggerating. I don't know. I used to say to myself, I'd look in the mirror in the morning and go, I don't know if this is sustainable. How am I going to get through the day? And then we would just keep filming, filming, filming, filming. And in those days, editing, we, I'm probably, I don't know if this is accurate, but I'm probably one of the only women in reality television world that has editing rights to our show.
我没有夸张。我不知道。我过去常对自己说，我早上照镜子时会想，我不知道这能否持续下去。我怎么才能熬过这一天？然后我们就一直拍，拍，拍，拍。而在那些日子里，剪辑，我，我可能，我不知道这准不准确，但我可能是真人秀电视世界里唯一一个对我们的节目拥有剪辑权的女性。
I am able to take anything out. And that was from the very start? From day one. I said, I'm not doing this unless I. So the key to our success. And you could tell the kids, don't worry about it. You just let it all fly because at the end of the day. Right.
我能够删掉任何内容。从一开始就是这样？从第一天起。我说，除非我能……否则我不会做这个。所以这是我们成功的关键。你可以告诉孩子们，别担心。你们就顺其自然吧，因为归根结底。对。
And you know what's interesting about that is. over the years from day one, when we knew we had that freedom and that kind of power, so to speak, it made us more comfortable. It made us be the way we always are and how we're bonded together as a family because we're very close to each other.
你知道关于这个有趣的是，
And we were able to say things that were, you know, very intimate or, you know, only our family knew or whatever it was. But things started. to, you know, develop in a way that we, I was thinking to myself, you know, oh my goodness, this is really crazy. And knowing that we could take it out, and you know, we never did. We would come, we would have a meeting and we would say, you know, the FBI showed up today,
多年来，从第一天起，当我们知道我们拥有那种自由和权力，可以说，这让我们感到更舒适。这让我们保持了我们一贯的样子，以及我们作为一家人是如何紧密联系在一起的，因为我们彼此非常亲密。
you know, or Kylie ended up in season, episode one, season one is a nine-year-old child on a stripper pole. And I had the, you know, and I'm looking at the footage going, how did this happen? How did this happen? I left Kim and Robin Anton in a room for five minutes and Kylie's on a stripper pole. You know, so it was really insane. Anyway, it turns out that the things that I would remove or take out ended up to be, oh my God, the back of my hair looks crazy. Take that out. Or I look so fat. It keeps you human. Or can somebody fix my lipstick? Like, what?
我们能够说出一些，你知道的，非常私密的话，或者，你知道的，只有我们家人知道的事，无论是什么。但事情开始，你知道的，以一种我们，我当时在想，你知道，哦，天哪，这真的太疯狂了。而且知道我们可以把它删掉，你知道，我们从来没这样做过。我们会来，我们会开个会，我们会说，你知道，FBI今天来了，
So that's the, I was so vain in, like, I had never really been on, I had been on TV, and I had done QVC and I had done things with Bruce Jenner and, you know, all this stuff. But I'd never been on a television show at home. That was unscripted like that. And it was a very vulnerable feeling. I wanted to ask, so about that. So that starts to happen. So, right, so the vulnerability I can only imagine.
你知道，或者在第一季第一集里，凯莉作为九岁的小女孩出现在了钢管舞杆上。而我当时有，你知道的，我看着素材心想，这怎么发生的？这怎么发生的？我把金和罗宾·安东留在房间里五分钟，凯莉就上了钢管舞杆。你知道，所以这真的很疯狂。不管怎样，事实证明，那些我想要移除或删掉的东西，最后却变成了，哦，天哪，我的头发看起来太疯狂了。删掉那个。或者我看起来太胖了。这让你保持人性。或者有人能帮我修修口红吗？比如，什么？
because we know what it's like a little bit. We talked about it earlier about stuff happens and then people out in the world have a right to comment on it, especially now in real time and stuff just right. Right, right. To go through that experience, especially early on when it was like early social media days when you guys started, it was really early.
所以这就是，我太虚荣了，就像，我从来没有真正上过，我上过电视，我做过QVC，我和布鲁斯·詹纳做过节目，你知道，所有这些。但我从来没有在家里上过这样的电视节目。像那样没有剧本的。那是一种非常脆弱的感觉。我想问，关于那个。所以事情开始发生。所以，对，这种脆弱感我只能想象，
I mean, and to have people commenting on your life on your parenting, like you say, with the stripper poll. have opinions. All the thing, and your kids growing up and people have opinions in real time. There's nobody bigger than you guys at a certain point. You sort of, you guys rocket to fame
因为我们对那种感觉略知一二。我们之前谈过，事情发生了，然后外面世界的人就有权对其发表评论，尤其是现在实时发生的事情。对，对。经历那种经历，尤其是早期，当你们开始时那是社交媒体的早期阶段，真的非常早。
and everybody in the world has an opinion on you and your family and your kids and blah, blah, blah. How did you kind of meet that and ride with that over the years? As you say, you just finished season 28. You've obviously found a place in a way to accommodate that.
我是说，当人们对你的生活、对你的育儿方式发表评论时，就像你说的，关于钢管舞杆。有各种意见。所有这些，你的孩子们在成长，而人们在实时发表意见。在某个特定阶段，没有人比你们更红了。你们可以说是火箭般蹿红，
But what was that like? What was that learning curve? of like to deal with that? You know what? I think it was one day at a time. It was leaning on each other. It was learning from one another. It was understanding that it takes an entire village to do what we do.
全世界每个人对你、对你的家庭、对你的孩子等等都有意见。多年来，你是如何面对并驾驭这一切的？正如你所说，你刚刚完成了第28季。你显然已经找到了一个位置和一种方式来适应这一点。
And then it was all these realizations over the years that occurred to us. And first of all, we had to have really thick skin. And I said to my kids very early on, because they were a lot younger. I mean, when I started the show, I had no grandchildren. Now I have 13. I mean, life changes so fast. That's amazing. So I said to my children, because they were young enough for me to tell them what to do still.
但那是什么感觉？那种学习曲线是什么样的？去应对这些？你知道吗？我想这是一天一天来的。是彼此依靠。是互相学习。是理解到做我们所做的事需要整个村庄的力量。
And I do tell them what to do every single day, but sometimes they don't listen. So I told them, nobody's going on the Internet. nobody's engaging in the bullshit. And that was after the first episode. And, you know, I had even close friends that I trusted that would have one eyebrow up going, really? The stripper pole? Not knowing that Oprah just had the stripper pole,
然后是这些年来发生在我们身上所有这些顿悟。首先，我们必须脸皮非常厚。我在非常早的时候就对我的孩子们说，因为他们当时小得多。我是说，当我开始这个节目时，我没有孙辈。现在我有13个。我是说，生活变化太快了。太惊人了。所以我对我的孩子们说，因为他们还足够小，我还可以告诉他们该怎么做。
you know, on an episode of her show because it was the new exercise, you know, craziness that everybody was doing this. And, you know, Robin Anton had come over to show Kim how to use it because Kim had bought me one for Mother's. Day and to do my exercise, you know, and Kylie ends up on it. But, you know, it was just they wanted to edit it a certain way. And it wasn't really edited. It was just like people took it a certain way. And I just said, let it fly. We know what happened. Like, who cares? Yeah, I was
而且我确实每天都告诉他们该怎么做，但有时他们不听。所以我告诉他们，谁也不准上网。谁也不准去掺和那些废话。那是第一集播出之后的事。而且，你知道，我甚至有一些我信任的挚友，他们会挑起一根眉毛说，真的吗？钢管舞杆？他们不知道奥普拉刚刚才用过钢管舞杆，
going to say, I would imagine that a lot of this stuff, the element of the world now being, having access inside the the serenity of somebody's home, I can imagine would only make you guys closer in that you guys are the only ones that know the real story, who we really are, what we really feel juxtapose to this outside opinion multiplied by millions, I guess you were kind of forced to quickly say, well, that's their kind of idea, their opinion, their narrative, versus what the real thing is almost makes you guys even more solid and intimate and a unit. Yes? I think so.
你知道，在她节目的某一集里，因为那是当时每个人都在做的最新健身狂潮。而且，你知道，罗宾·安东过来教金怎么用，因为金为了母亲节给我买了一个，让我用来锻炼，你知道，结果凯莉却上去了。但是，你知道，他们只是想用某种特定的方式来剪辑。它其实并没有被剪辑，只是人们以某种特定的方式看待它。我只是说，随它去吧。我们知道发生了什么。谁在乎呢？是的，我
I think we felt really close. We felt like we could always help each other out. I remember, you know, when we first started the show, for example, there was no Instagram. There was no Snapchat. There was barely Twitter. And Ryan C. Chris called me up one day and he goes, you know, you might want to tell Kim about this little thing called Twitter. I'm not really sure what it is. I'm like Twitter. What is Twitter? And so, you know, Kim, you got to get on Twitter. And, you know, we just helped each other learn and
要说的是，我能想象其中很多事情，现在这个世界能够进入并访问别人家中的宁静，我能想象这只会让你们更加亲密，因为你们是唯一知道真实故事的人，我们真正是谁，我们真正感受到的是什么，与外部数以百万计的意见相悖，我想你们很快就被迫说，好吧，那是他们的想法、他们的意见、他们的叙事，而真实的事情几乎让你们变得更加坚固、亲密和一个整体。是吗？我想是的。
grow and it takes a village to do what we're doing. And then on top of all of it, the years went by and we realized how many thousands of people we employ who the network employees, the people that benefit and have, we've had people that work for us for years, write to us, like write notes to us and say, you know, and hand them to us and say, thank you for changing my life. Thank you for giving me purpose. Thank you for giving me a job. Thank you for, you know, so you start with the smallest things, the assistants, the glam teams, the people who are getting us from one point to another, the all the fashion side of it. The, you know, it's just tends, you know, thousands and thousands of people.
我觉得我们感到非常亲密。我们觉得我们总能互相帮助。我记得，你知道，当我们刚开始做这个节目时，比如，没有Instagram。没有Snapchat。几乎没有Twitter。瑞安·西克雷斯特有一天打电话给我说，你知道的，你可能想把这个叫Twitter的小东西告诉金。我其实不太清楚那是什么。我说Twitter。什么是Twitter？所以，你知道，金，你得注册Twitter。而且，你知道，我们只是互相帮助学习和
And then as time went on, and we started making money, and we were able to give back to things that meant a lot to us and help people that were less fortunate. And that felt good. So it's been an evolution of our whole process. Yeah. And even specifically what the social media has done, it wasn't around when you started now.
成长，做我们正在做的事需要整个村庄的力量。然后最重要的是，岁月流逝，我们意识到我们雇佣了成千上万的人，电视网雇佣了多少人，那些受益的人，我们有多年来为我们工作的人，写信给我们，比如给我们写便条，并说，你知道的，亲手交给我们并说，谢谢你改变了我的生活。谢谢你给我目标。谢谢你给我一份工作。谢谢你，你知道的，所以你从最小的事情开始，助理、化妆团队，把我们从一个地方带到另一个地方的人，所有时尚方面的人。你知道的，这只是倾向于，你知道，成千上万的人。
Of course, it's around. But the way in which you guys are such a presence there as well. And talk to us a bit about how that, I think, help me, educate me. It is one of the major engines to some of the stuff that you guys do, sort of your brand positioning and leveraging one and being spokesmen for other things. It all sort of exists almost entirely on some of it on this platform versus, you know, linear TV and and whatnot. Right. It's how the business has evolved for many businesses around the world,
当然，它确实存在。但你们在那里如此具有存在感的方式。跟我们聊聊这如何，我想，启发我，教育我。这是你们所做的一些事情的主要驱动力之一，比如你们的品牌定位以及利用其中一个并为其他事情代言。这一切几乎完全存在于这个平台上，而相比之下，你知道的，传统电视之类的不多。没错。这就是许多企业业务的演变方式，
you know, having this example that started actually when Kim got on Twitter, that first, that example I gave you when she first learned about it. And I remember she was the first one who really, she really educated us about, meaning my family and I, about how she could communicate with the audience and be a part of the Twitter universe by engaging in these conversations. And she genuinely loved it.
你知道，这个例子其实是从金开始玩推特时开始的，我给你们讲的那个她刚了解它的例子。我记得她是第一个真正向我们，也就是我和我的家人，普及如何通过参与这些对话来与受众沟通并成为推特世界的一部分的人。她是发自内心地喜欢它。
Like she would, I remember the first time, and I think she was the first one to do this, she sent a tweet to her fans and to all the viewers of our show whenever, just out there in the world. And she said, I'm going to launch this fragrance. And here are the two, you know, packaging options, the bottles. Do you guys like this choice or this choice?
就像她会，我记得第一次，而且我认为她是第一个这么做的人，她向她的粉丝以及我们节目的所有观众发了一条推特，每当她在外面的时候。她说，我要推出这款香水。这里有两个，你知道的，包装选项，瓶子。你们喜欢这个选择还是那个选择？
You know, the pink or the black or whatever it was. And the response was overwhelming. And I knew that she was so smart and so, not that it was, you know, she wasn't in any way being manipulative. She was being genuinely wanting her own, focus group. She was able to, you know, put together this group of people that she, that was, that she, no one would have had had access to in the entire world, except for her. And as her numbers grew, her audience grew, our audience grew. And then one by one is as different
你知道的，粉色还是黑色，或者不管是什么。反响极其热烈。我知道她是如此聪明，并且，并不是说，你知道的，她有任何操纵的意图。她只是发自内心地想要她自己的焦点小组。她能够，你知道的，把这群人聚集在一起，这群人，那是，她，世界上没有任何人能拥有这样的接触权限，除了她。随着她的数字增长，她的受众增长，我们的受众也增长。然后一个接一个，随着不同的
social media platforms emerged and were developed. And as all of my, you know, me and my, my children all became very active on all these social media platforms and the numbers grew and it just snowballed and I think like if you added up all the numbers and you added up all the kids and all the platforms there's a couple, you know, and our global network with Disney and we're our shows in over 200 countries and on and on every single day
社交媒体平台的涌现和发展。随着我所有的，你知道的，我和我的孩子们都开始在所有这些社交媒体平台上非常活跃，数字不断增长，就像滚雪球一样，我想如果你把所有的数字加起来，把所有的孩子和所有的平台加起来，有好几个，你知道的，还有我们与迪士尼的全球网络，我们的节目在200多个国家播出，而且每天都在继续，
and Disney just bought the rights to keeping up with the Kardashians they just bought all the archive So, you know, there's billions of people daily who are... Not only that, you said that you, you know, thousands of people you employed, if you think about it, you launched an entire industry in that you guys were the first people to understand the power of, as you pointed out that example with Kim, of using social media and creating that, and Jason says sort of establishing the brand and putting that out there, all these people in the world who now make a living doing that,
而且迪士尼刚刚买下了《与卡戴珊同行》的版权，他们买下了所有的档案。所以，你知道的，每天有数十亿人在……不仅如此，你刚才说你，你知道的，你雇用了成千上万的人，仔细想想，你们开创了一个整个行业，因为你们是第一批理解，正如你指出的金的那个例子，利用社交媒体并创造这种力量的人，杰森说这有点像建立品牌并将其推广出去，世界上现在有这么多人靠做这个谋生，
They all have really, in effect, you guys to think. Well, it's also now, it's the major engine for many of the mainstream traditional legacy companies. Corporations all took it from you guys, everybody. Yeah. Airlines to media companies, to oil companies, like everybody wants to figure out how to harness the power of that direct one-to-one connection to your customer. And it's about reach. It's about connecting with the people that are actually engaged with your product. You guys have this enormous power and influence in that space. I would imagine, and you don't have to answer this,
实际上，他们都真的要感谢你们。好吧，现在这也是许多主流传统老牌公司的主要驱动力。大公司都从你们这里学去了，所有人都是。是的。从航空公司到传媒公司，再到石油公司，每个人都想弄清楚如何驾驭这种与客户一对一直接连接的力量。这就是关于触达。这就是关于与真正与你们的产品产生互动的人建立联系。你们在这个领域拥有巨大的权力和影响力。我猜想，虽然你们不必回答这个，
but I would imagine that you're constantly being courted, solicited by any number of companies to help them understand how they can reach more of their customers, stay engaged with them, amplify what it is that they do. Chris, wait until you see, Jay. Jason's hair, hair thing they just said for Jen, for Anna. It's amazing. We're true, you know, listen, everyone's trying. That's right, babe.
但我猜想你们一定经常受到无数公司的追求和恳求，希望你们能帮他们了解如何才能触达更多客户、与他们保持互动、放大他们的所作所为。克里斯，等你看过这个，杰。杰森给珍、给安娜弄的那个头发。太棒了。真的，你知道的，听着，每个人都在尝试。没错，宝贝。
We'll be right back. And back to the show. I would bet it's, you can be, you could probably spend all your time just trying to educate people on how to, how to best integrate. Utilize their, yeah, their social media. Well, it's like when Kylie launched her lip kit in, you know, all those, 10 years ago. it was insane because I went to her about, I don't know, a month before the launch, knowing that she was going to create this thing. She goes, Mom, I know what I want to do for the rest of my life.
我们马上回来。欢迎回到节目中。我敢打赌，你可以，你可能把所有的时间都花在教导别人如何如何最好地整合。利用他们的，是的，他们的社交媒体上。好吧，就像10年前凯莉推出她的唇膏套装时一样，你知道的，那太疯狂了，因为我在她推出前大约一个月去找她，当时我知道她要创造这个东西。她说，妈妈，我知道我这辈子想做什么。
And it's beauty. And I want to, you know, do this lip kit. And now you've got to take this and run with it and figure out how to make it. And so I contacted some people I knew that could do this. They made it. And I said, so what are we doing about the marketing? Like, you know, we need an ad in People magazine. and we need to have a billboard.
那就是美妆。我想，你知道的，做这个唇膏套装。现在你得把这个接过去并把它办成，弄清楚怎么生产它。所以我联系了一些我认识的能做这个的人。他们把它生产出来了。我说，那我们在营销方面要做什么？比如，你知道的，我们需要在《人物》杂志上登广告，我们需要一个巨型广告牌。
And she goes, are we okay, Mom? Like, I know what I'm doing. Just relax. And I said, I can't relax. You just spent every dime you've ever made on keeping up with the Kardashians to start your own brand by yourself with your own money.
她说，我们还好吗，妈妈？就像，我知道我在做什么。放松点。我说我无法放松。你刚刚花光了你从《与卡戴珊同行》中赚到的每一分钱，用你自己的钱独自创立你自己的品牌。
And I'm a little nervous. Mom's a little, you know, you're 17 years old. So what are you doing? And she said, I know what I'm doing. And so I'll never forget the morning she launched her brand, which was the first time she disrupted. an entire beauty business because she pressed send
我有点紧张。妈妈有点，你知道的，你才17岁。那你到底在干什么？她说，我知道我在做什么。所以我永远不会忘记她推出品牌的那天早上，那是她第一次颠覆整个美妆行业，因为她按下了发送键，
on the link to go buy this and put a post out, go buy my lip kit, and I think it was four seconds and we thought the site crashed because we had to launch, you know,
点击购买的链接并发布了一条帖子，去买我的唇膏套装吧，我想那是四秒钟，我们以为网站崩溃了，因为我们得发布，你知道的，
and it was just sold out in seconds. And then we knew, you know, and she developed, that was her, and then it was on. She was the first one to do that.
而且几秒钟内就售罄了。然后我们就知道了，你知道的，她开发了，那是她的产品，接着就一发不可收拾了。她是第一个这么做的人。
We need to have a meeting with you offline. We need to have an hour meeting with you. Okay, guys, come on over. I'm in Chloe's podcast. She'll never know. So when you say one of the first, do you mean about how sort of the brick and mortar sort of model of?
我们需要和你线下开个会。我们需要和你开一个小时的会。好吧，伙计们，过来吧。我在科勒的播客上。她永远不会知道。所以当你说是第一批的时候，你是指实体店的那种模式吗？
Yeah. Yeah, I think how to sell a beauty brand online like that had never been done or any brand. And also, I think Kim was probably the first to ever sell a fragrance. Think about this. millions of fragrances online without ever smelling it. Yeah. Wow. Is that not crazy?
对。对，我认为是如何在线上销售美妆品牌，这以前从未有过，任何品牌都是如此。而且，我也认为金可能是第一个销售香水的人。想想看。在线上销售数百万瓶香水，而人们甚至从未闻过。哇。这难道不疯狂吗？
Yeah, I'll take that fragrance. And you've never, you're trusting that you want to smell like Kim. Meanwhile, it's still, the first fragrance is still the fragrance that I wear. Really? Every day and every day somebody goes, oh, what is that? You smell so good. So I'm so proud of that moment for her. How was the smelling sessions for?
对，我买那款香水。而你甚至从未，你只是相信你想闻起来像金。与此同时，它仍然，第一款香水仍然是我每天都在使用的香水。真的吗？每天都有人问，哦，那是什么？你闻起来太香了。所以我为她那个时刻感到非常骄傲。当时的气味测试是怎样的？
that as you guys were developing that, sniffing a bunch of stuff and narrowing down what the scent would be. Kim and I, yeah, Kim and I went to a fragrance company in New York a few times. And by the way, this whole journey, everything I'm telling you, all the stories I could go on for days, is all on film for keeping up with the Kardashians and now the Kardashians. And that I'm so grateful for because I have the best. home movies in the world. Yeah. And I have all these beautiful, I mean, I remember we were filming,
当你们在开发那个产品时，闻了一堆东西并缩小范围来确定气味会是什么样的。金和我，是的，金和我有几次去了纽约的一家香水公司。顺便说一句，这段旅程，我告诉你的这一切，我可以讲上好几天的所有故事，都被《与卡戴珊同行》以及现在的《卡戴珊家族》记录在案了。对此我非常感激，因为我有世界上最好的家庭录像。是的。而且我有所有这些美好的，我的意思是，我记得我们在拍摄，
we filmed the birth of Mason. Good God. And I'm like, we film that? Like I sit and go, we film that? But we did. I always think that's wild because my sister just sent me an audio clip that she found when she was 12 years old. And it's really scratchy and you can barely hear it.
我们拍摄了梅森的出生。天啊。我说，我们把那也拍进去了？就像我坐在那儿想，我们把那拍进去了？但我们确实拍了。我一直觉得这太疯狂了，因为我姐姐刚刚发给我一段音频剪辑，那是她12岁时找到的。而且声音真的很嘶哑，几乎听不清。
You can tell it's her, which is so different than how kids grow up now. They have everything. they have home movies every day, you know, because of social media. And it's high quality. It looks like yesterday. Yeah, it looks like yesterday. So it's a weird thing about how memories now are stored in our brains. The kids now store it differently than the four of us do because we didn't have that.
你能看出那是她，这和现在孩子们长大后的情况太不一样了。他们拥有一切，你知道的，因为社交媒体，他们每天都有家庭录像。而且质量很高。看起来就像昨天一样。是的，看起来就像昨天一样。所以这是一件很奇怪的事情，关于现在的记忆是如何储存在我们大脑中的。现在的孩子们储存记忆的方式和我们四个不同，因为我们以前没有那些。
You know, it's not archived as a kid. We didn't have any archives. Right. Can I ask you guys a question? Yeah. Capricorn. Off topic. Okay, good.
你知道，作为小孩子时它并没有被存档。我们没有任何档案。对。我能问你们一个问题吗？可以。摩羯座。跑题了。好吧，很好。
So do any of you ever go back? And really look at the photos. Yeah, I do. You have a million of in your phone? You do? Mostly of my kids. Oh, no, not my phone. No, not in the phone.
你们有谁会回头去真正看看那些照片吗？会的，我会。你手机里有一百万张？真的吗？大部分是我孩子的。哦，不，不是我的手机。不，不是在手机里。
When I was a kid, like the actual hard copy photo that was taken. Yeah. Yeah, yeah. So, you know what I do? Every year, at the end of the year, before January 1st, I edit all my photos in my phone. So I, you know how you take 75 photos of one thing. Yeah. Edit, edit, edit, get it to where those photos on your phone or what you love.
当我还是个孩子的时候，比如拍下来的那种真正的纸质照片。是的。所以，你知道我做什么吗？每年年底，在1月1日之前，我都会编辑我手机里的所有照片。所以，你知道你会对同一件事拍75张照片。是的。编辑，编辑，编辑，把它精简到你手机上留下的那些都是你最喜欢的。
of. Right. And there's probably 3,000 or whatever there is. Oh, God, that's a big job. I have them taken to a very trusted printer that I've been using for since the early 90s, literally. And they print them out, and I put them in an archival photo box, and they're in my archive, and I have a hard copy of every single photo that I've ever taken. Because I'm probably the only one in my family who will do that so that, you know, many, many moons from now.
对。可能总共有3,000张左右。哦，天哪，那是个大工程。我把它们送到一个我从90年代初就一直使用的非常值得信赖的冲印店，千真万确。他们把照片冲印出来，我把它们放进一个档案照片盒里，它们放在我的档案里，我对我拍过的每一张照片都有纸质备份。因为我可能是我家里唯一会做这件事的人，所以，你知道的，在许多许多岁月之后，
they can look back and go, I remember this. Like going through the photos is such a thing for me and how I have memories of my family, my grandmother, and, you know, so I think everybody should go copy their phone once a year. That's a great idea. And archive it in a box. I think I get them at like the container store or something. But there's archival boxes.
他们可以回过头去说，我记得这个。翻看照片对我和我如何拥有关于我的家人、我的祖母的记忆来说是一件意义重大的事，所以我觉得每个人每年都应该去把手机里的照片打印备份一次。这主意真不错。然后存档在盒子里。我想我是从像The Container Store那类地方买的。不过有专门的无酸档案盒。
You can get them on Amazon. And they protect the photo. But for everyone who has kids, you know, it's so special. Yeah, it is. That's my tip for the day. You should have a party and just go through each page one by one, right? And just do like a four-day party of just like each page.
你可以在亚马逊上买到。它们能保护照片。但对于所有有孩子的家庭来说，你知道，这太特别了。是的，确实如此。这就是我今天的建议。你应该办个派对，然后一页一页地翻看，对吧？就搞一个为期四天的派对，专门看每一页。
Or turn on keeping up with the Kardashians. Yeah, or just that. Chris, with all of your incredible business success, I bet you're most proud of what seems to be an incredible ability to be both. a manager and a mother to not one but six of your children and and wear both of those hats in a way because my parents were my manager as well when I was growing up and I remember that was a it was a tricky challenging thing for both them and me to to manage together and yeah and try to keep both of those sides of our lives pristine
或者打开看《与卡戴珊同行》。是的，或者就那样。克里斯，凭着你所有不可思议的商业成功，我敢打赌你最自豪的是你似乎拥有一种不可思议的能力，能够同时胜任经理和母亲两个角色，而且不是对一个孩子，而是对你六个孩子中的每一个，把这两个身份都扮演得很好，因为我小时候，我的父母也是我的经理，我记得对我父母和我来说，这都是一件棘手且具有挑战性的事情，要一起处理，并且，是的，试图让生活中的这两部分都保持纯粹
and honored, and where one is sort of like a peer relationship, and the other one is that sort of traditional deferential relationship where, you know, the kid looks up to the parent and completely listens to and defers to and follows behind kind of thing. So they're not at odds with one another, but there's a few areas of overlap, but they are different, you know? And so your ability to do that, it seems, been incredibly successful because all your kids from what I can see just seem incredibly well
并受到尊重，其中一部分有点像同辈关系，而另一部分则是那种传统的顺从关系，你知道的，孩子崇拜父母，完全听从、服从并跟随父母的那种关系。所以它们彼此并不冲突，但有一些重叠的领域，不过它们是不同的，你知道吗？所以你能够做到这一点，似乎取得了难以置信的成功，因为据我所能看到的，你所有的孩子看起来都极其脚踏实地
grounded and kind. So can you talk a little about that? I think, first of all, my most important role is mom. So I recognize that and that's the most important thing in my life. And I feel like God has put me here at this point in my life to make sure they're okay. And I think every parent's dream is for your child to identify what they want to do in their life and go out there and find how their dream can come true, help them get there, set them off and set them up, and good to go. Like that's my, I mean, when I think about my kids and I go down the line and go, okay, today, this one's okay, I got to do the, you know, but in general, to have your kids at a really good, happy place, whether they want to be a housewife and a mom, whether they want to be an athlete,
且善良。所以你能多谈谈这一点吗？首先，我认为我最重要的角色是妈妈。所以我意识到了这一点，这是我生命中最重要的事情。我觉得上帝把我带到我生命的这个阶段，是为了确保他们没事。而且我认为每个父母的梦想都是让你的孩子明确他们想在生活中做什么，然后走出去，找到他们的梦想如何实现的方法，帮助他们到达那里，让他们出发并为他们做好准备，一切就绪。就像那是我的，我的意思是，当我想到我的孩子们，然后挨个看过去，心想，好吧，今天这个没事，我得去做，你知道的，但总的来说，让你的孩子处于一个真正美好、快乐的状态，无论他们想成为家庭主妇和母亲，还是想成为运动员，
whatever their dream is, if they're happy. And the most important thing for me is I always say, God first, family, second, everything else is third. And I've always raised my children like that. And I've always raised my kids to be, all that matters to me is that they have good hearts. They have integrity, character, great character, great integrity. They would help people that in need, that need them. and they're kind.
无论他们的梦想是什么，只要他们快乐。对最我重要的事是，我总是说，上帝第一，家庭第二，其他一切排第三。我一直都是这样抚养我的孩子的。我一直把我的孩子们抚养得，对我而言唯一重要的是他们拥有一颗善良的心。他们有正直、品格，优秀的品格，极高的正直。他们会帮助那些有需要、需要他们的人，而且他们很善良。
Be on time. Be kind. Be gentle with people. You never know what kind of a day they've been having. But stick up for yourself and be strong when you need to be strong. And all the things. Sure. You know, all the things.
守时。善良。对人温和。你永远不知道他们一直在经历怎样的一天。但要在需要坚强的时候坚持自我，保持坚强。诸如此类。当然。你知道，就是所有这些。
And it means the most to me when I hear other people's experiences with my kids. And daily, if I show up to something and someone's been their, before me. Like, let's say I was on this podcast and maybe one of my kids had done it, or I, you know, somebody came up to me Saturday night at a dinner and said, I have the store in over here where we were and your children come in there from time to time and I've never met more kind, you know, gentle people in my life. They're the nicest people I've ever met. Every time I hear that, my heart just swells. I'm so happy because that's all that matters. Yeah, you know what, Chris, it's funny you say that.
当听到别人对我的孩子们的评价时，这对我意义重大。每天，如果我出现在某个地方，而有人已经提前去过那里了。比方说我上了这个播客，也许我的一个孩子曾经上过，或者我，你知道的，周六晚上在一家餐厅有人走过来对我说，我们在那边有个店，你们的孩子不时会去那里，我从未见过比他们更善良、你知道的、更温和的人了。他们是我见过的最好的人。每次我听到这个，我的内心都会一阵狂喜。我太高兴了因为这才是最重要的。是的，你知道吗，克里斯，你这么说真有意思。
So I was going to say, and you guys will relate to this, is there's no greater feeling than when somebody says to you, hey, I just ran into your kids, your kids are great, that your kids are so nice. It feels so good. You never get tired of hearing that. Never. When somebody compliments your kid on their character, ever. And I will say this, I don't know your kids.
所以我想说的是，你们会感同身受的，没有比听到别人对你说“嘿，我刚刚遇到你的孩子们，你的孩子们真棒，你的孩子们真好”时更棒的感觉了。这种感觉太美妙了。你永远听不腻这种话。永远不会。当有人称赞你的孩子品行好时，永远不会。我要这么说，我不认识你的孩子。
And I, but I have heard, and this is anecdotal, but I have heard time and time again over the years what nice people your kids are. I'm not making this up. I have heard that so many times. That makes me so happy. It's absolutely true. Yeah. Absolutely.
而且我，但我听说过，这只是传闻，但我这些年来一次又一次地听到人们说你的孩子们是多么好的人。我不是在编造。我听过太多次了。这让我太开心了。这绝对是真的。是的。绝对的。
I've had a couple of bad encounters. I'm just going to be honest. That's different, Sean. That's different, Sean, though. I mean, you're so confrontational. Sean, we can't hear you anymore. Sorry, Ben. Yep.
我有过几次糟糕的经历。我只是实话实说。那不一样，肖恩。不过那不一样，肖恩。我的意思是，你太具有对抗性了。肖恩，我们听不见你说话了。抱歉，本。是的。
I think your mic went out. No, lovely. I, too, have met them, and they're just so genuine. They love you. I love them. I love you. I have that great time. I know.
我想你的麦克风没声音了。不，挺好的。我也见过他们，他们就是那么真诚。他们爱你们。我爱他们。我爱你们。我度过了那段美好的时光。我知道。
I know. I know. I know. A secret date. I'm going to text you right after this. Okay. Wait, text, text me. Do I still, you guys? I have your number. I would imagine that, I mean, your days, my God, I can't imagine how full your days are. With all the business stuff, all the parenting stuff, you'd have to delegate a great deal.
我知道。我知道。我知道。一个秘密约会。我录完这个就给你发短信。好的。等等，发短信，发短信给我。我还有吗，你们？我有你的电话号码。我想象得出，我的意思是，你的日子，天哪，我无法想象你的日子有多满。所有的商业事务，所有的育儿事务，你一定得授权委派很多事情。
And I'm sure you've got incredible people around you. But what is the thing that you simply cannot. delegate, will not delegate. Well, let's put it this way. At the end of the day, especially lately, the year started off like, whoa, like if you were on a treadmill at like level 62.
而且我确信你身边有不可思议的人。但是，有什么事情是你绝对无法委派、也绝不会委派的呢？好吧，我们这样说吧。一天结束的时候，尤其是最近，这一年开始时就像是，哇，就像你在跑步机上以62档的速度跑步一样。
Yeah. I get at the end of the day decision fatigue. Yeah. If you can imagine. Like I start off so early, like at 5 a.m., I let people have access to me at that hour, meaning
是的。我在一天结束时会产生决策疲劳。是的。如果你能想象得到的话。我开始得很早，比如早上5点，我在那个时间就允许人们联系我，意思是说
I alert people, hey, we're rolling. You know, I'll call an attorney, I'll text an attorney, a business manager, somebody in Europe, somebody in New York, like, okay, we're ready to go. And it never ends. So I think that, you know, just being able to juggle, I feel like sometimes, some days are like that guy in the circus where he's got the plates in the air and you just keep taking the stick and spinning them all, you know, just making sure they're all spinning. Some days, if they're like that, that's a chill day.
我会提醒大家，嘿，我们要开始了。你知道的，我会给律师打电话，给律师、业务经理、在欧洲的某个人、在纽约的某个人发短信，说，好吧，我们准备好开始了。而且这永远不会结束。所以我觉得，你知道的，仅仅是能够应付这一切，我觉得有时，有些天就像马戏团里那个玩盘子的家伙，盘子在空中，你只要不停地拿过棍子让它们继续转，你知道的，只是确保它们都在转。有些天，如果它们是那样的话，那就是轻松的一天。
Right. But if it's really buckling down, putting out fires, I mean, most days I'm a fireman. So putting out fires, making sure everybody's okay. And then, like this morning, I got a very, like a 6 a.m. call from Kylie. And she just wanted to, you know, go through something personal that she was, like, wanting an opinion on. So stop the, you know, the mom at your hat, roll into, okay, and I just got my coffee again and sat down and listened to the whole thing, gave my opinion, we're good to go. She goes, okay, it's going to be okay, mommy. It's going to be great.
对。但如果真的是全力以赴、到处救火，我的意思是，大多数时候我都是个消防员。所以就是救火，确保每个人都好好的。然后，就像今天早上，我接到了凯莉打来的一个非常早的电话，大概早上6点。她只是想，你知道的，讨论一些她想要征求意见的个人事情。所以得放下，你知道的，切换到妈妈的角色，好吧，我刚刚又喝了咖啡，坐下来听完了整件事，给出了我的意见，我们就搞定了。她说，好吧，会没事的，妈妈。一切都会很好的。
Okay, we're good. And so everybody needs, you know, that emotional check-in every day. And we all just, like, I get a million times a day from Chloe. I love you, mom. Mom, you're the best. And my kids are so, Kim and I, for the last two days, texting, you know, all day from London and then Paris because she's at the Skim's opening in those two cities. Yeah. And then, you know, so there's always business to talk about.
好吧，我们很好。所以每个人都需要，你知道的，每天都有那种情感上的慰藉。我们所有人都，就像我一天从克洛伊那里听到一百万次一样。妈妈，我爱你。妈妈，你是最棒的。我的孩子们太，金和我，在过去的两天里，整天都在发短信，你知道的，先是从伦敦然后是巴黎，因为她在参加这两个城市的Skims开业活动。是的。然后，你知道的，所以总有商业上的事情要谈。
And then an influx of photos from the event that they're at or, you know, all of it, you know, all of it. And it's been great. It's a great journey. What kind of crisis would it be if you? woke up one day and you forgot to plug your phone in overnight. Well, that would be bad. Right? You didn't.
接着还有他们所在的活动的照片源源不断地发过来，或者，你知道的，所有这些，你知道的，所有这些。这真的很棒。这是一段伟大的旅程。如果你有一天醒来，发现自己忘记在前一天晚上给手机充电，那会是什么样的危机？嗯，那可就糟了。对吧？你没有。
That would be bad. But I would imagine, even waking up with a full charge, you're charging that phone around four o'clock every day anyway. Yeah. Right? Yeah. Oh, my God. For sure.
那可就糟了。但我可以想象，即使醒来时电量是满的，你反正每天下午四点左右也还是会给那部手机充电。对吧？对吧？哦，天哪。肯定的。
For sure. Especially if you have like a little Zoom in between. Yeah. Yeah. That's a little bit of a dreamer. But it's, yeah, no, you just, you know, you have to be prepared and ready for everything, I guess. I think I'm, I'm great at multitasking.
肯定的。特别是如果你中间还要开个Zoom会议的话。对吧？对吧。那有点像是白日梦。不过，是的，不，你只是，你知道的，你必须为一切做好准备和防范，我想。我觉得我，我非常擅长多任务处理。
Yeah. And I'm great. at, I think I have, you know, emotionally, I'm pretty strong. I cry on a dime. I'll cry at a commercial. Or, you know, or if I think about something really sad, I'll, you know, I get all welly. So I try to stay out of that danger zone. I try to, like, we don't need any tears today.
是的，而且我很擅长，我觉得我有，你知道的，在情感上，我相当坚强。我很容易哭。我看到商业广告都会哭。或者，你知道的，或者如果我想起一些非常伤心的事，我就会，你知道的，热泪盈眶。所以我尽量避开那个危险地带。我尽量提醒自己，今天不需要任何眼泪。
But I'm a very, I think I'm a very emotional person, but I think I have good, you know, emotional intelligence. You don't have to say who, but I would ask, is there somebody in your life or probably a few, maybe, that you can dump all this stuff on
但我是一个非常，我觉得我是一个非常有情感的人，但我认为我有很好的，你知道的，情感智力。你不用说出是谁，但我得问，你的生活中是不是有那么一个人，或者可能是有几个人，你可以把所有这些乱七八糟的事都倾倒给他们，
and you don't have to be the person who figures everything out. I'm sorry, Sean. Sean carries a weight around my family. It's insane. But you know what? I love it. Yeah, you do.
而你不需要扮演那个把所有事情都想清楚的人。对不起，肖恩。肖恩承担了我家族的重担。这太疯狂了。但你知道吗？我喜欢这样。对，你确实喜欢。
You're good at it too. You're very strong. What do you, what, what do people, think you control that you absolutely do not? A skim's discount. People wanting to get a little break because they know you. A skim's discount, yeah.
你也很擅长。你非常坚强。你认为，什么，人们认为你在掌控，但你实际上根本没有掌控？Skims的折扣。人们因为认识你而想捞点优惠。Skims的折扣，是的。
But Jason's previous question was good. Of course, you don't have to say names, but who is that? Who is that person that you get to lean on at the end of the day? Is it your kids? You know what? I'll tell you something. It depends on the subject and what's going on. I do have a selection.
不过杰森刚才的问题很好。当然，你不用说出名字，但那是谁？在一天结束时，谁是你能够依靠的那个人？是你的孩子们吗？你知道吗？我告诉你吧。这取决于主题和当时的情况。我确实有一些选择。
One of my best friends, Shelley Azov, is we'll talk about the craziest stuff and we just get each other. And then I don't have to talk to her for two weeks. She's not that person who's needy and needs me to, you know, emotionally check in with her all the time. And then my cousin, Cece. But, you know, and then Corey, my partner, of course, like my boyfriend, he's amazing. He's probably thinking, this is why. Like, sometimes I want to just go in his brain and, you know, wonder, he's probably thinking, what did I go into?
我最好的朋友之一，雪莉·阿佐夫（Shelley Azov），我们会聊最疯狂的事情，我们就是很合得来。然后我可以两周不和她说话。她不是那种需要人陪、需要你，你知道的，随时随地在情感上关注她的人。然后是我表妹茜茜。但是，你知道的，还有科里，我的伴侣，当然，就像我的男朋友，他太棒了。他可能在想，这就是原因。就像，有时我只想进入他的大脑，你知道的，好奇他心里在想，我到底是掉进什么里了？
But he loves us all so much and is so great. So, you know, obviously, the person that you live with is the person that probably hears and gets the brunt of it through and through. But you know who's so amazing and supportive are my kids? And each one for a different reason. Like if there's real drama with somebody, I'll tell you the time. I don't know how Chloe carries it. Chloe, you guys have to, you haven't had Chloe on yet, right? No, no, no.
但他非常爱我们所有人，而且太棒了。所以，你知道的，很显然，与你同住的那个人，可能就是最常听到并承受最多这一切的那个人。但你知道谁那么棒、那么支持我吗？是我的孩子们！而且每个人都有不同的原因。比如如果谁遇到了真正的戏剧性事件，我跟你讲讲。我不知道克洛伊是怎么承受这一切的。克洛伊，你们必须，你们还没请过克洛伊上节目吧？没有，没有，没有。
Chloe is such a great guest. Yeah. But Chloe, Chloe is a saint. She's an angel. She's not only is like the Pied Piper with all the kids, and she's the one who every single weekend has the sleepover and is making Taco Tuesdays for all the kids and having Bible study on Thursday nights for the kids at her house.
克洛伊是个多么棒的嘉宾啊。是的。但克洛伊，克洛伊是个圣人。她是个天使。她不仅是所有孩子们的“花衣魔笛手”（孩子王），她还是那种每个周末都会组织留宿派对的人，她会为所有孩子们做“玉米卷周二”，还在她家里为孩子们举办周四晚上的圣经学习班。
And I mean, she's like all the cousins. are, you know, she's the Pied Piper. She's the cutest thing ever. But she's also got such amazing, intense, emotional support to offer if you're going through something. And she's so intelligent about stuff. It's really great. And so's Kim. And all of them.
我的意思是，她就像所有表亲们的，你知道的，她就是那个孩子王。她可爱极了。但如果你经历了什么事情，她也能提供非常惊人、强烈的情感支持。而且她对事情很有悟性。真的太棒了。金也是。他们所有人都是。
I mean, I was talking to Kylie, like I said this morning, about something else. But they're all so, you know, Kendall's like my therapist. And if I want to talk about anything. in the environment, you know, Courtney's my go-to and she'll come over and throw all my pots and pans away. So, you know, they're all, we're all so connected. Yeah, but so when the house thinned out, because I'm dealing with this now, one just went off to college and my youngest, I've got another few years, but I'm already just like dreading being an empty nester. I'm just going to miss them so much. As your house started to thin out,
我是说，就像我刚才说的，我今天早上还在和凯莉聊别的事。但他们都那么，你知道的，肯达尔就像我的心理医生。如果我想聊聊环境方面的任何事，你知道的，考特尼就是我的首选，她会跑过来把我所有的锅碗瓢盆都扔掉。所以，你知道的，他们所有人，我们所有人都紧密相连。是的，但是当家里的人变少时，因为我现在正在经历这个，一个刚刚去上大学，我最小的孩子，我还有几年时间，但我已经开始害怕成为空巢老人了。我会非常想念他们的。随着你的家里开始冷清下来，
And now it's just you and Corey, right? Right. Well, okay, so the part that maybe you're missing is I live in a gated community. Yeah. And we all live down the street from each other. Right. So it's never. Chloe lives next door.
现在只有你和科里了，对吧？对。好吧，所以你可能忽略的部分是，我住在一个人脸识别的封闭式社区里。是的。而且我们都住在同一条街上。对。所以这从来都不是。克洛伊就住在隔壁。
She lives 50 feet away. Right. So it doesn't get any closer than that without being in the same bedroom. Right. That's great. And then I'll come home and, you know, I mean, Kendall's the only one who lives a little bit further but everyone we all live in the same area we're all at each other's houses and and you know I'll call Kim's house at least three times a week do you guys have any food over there I'm starving I
她就住在50英尺外。对。所以除了住在同一个卧室里，不可能再近了。对。那太棒了。然后我会回家，你知道的，我是说，肯达尔是唯一一个住得稍微远一点的人，但每个人，我们都住在同一个区，我们都在彼此的家里，而且，你知道的，我每周至少会给金家打三次电话，你们那边有什么吃的吗？我快饿死了，
don't buy it and then somebody runs over to get it and it's like it's very convenient I can only imagine that the holidays are just like this just like an idyllic just all those would you say 13 grandkids running around it's our Super Bowl it's It's delicious. And one of the kids has Christmas Eve. We usually do a big Christmas Eve party. And then I do Christmas morning. That's my tradition.
我没买吃的，然后就会有人跑过去拿，就像，这太方便了。我只能想象，假期就像这样，就像田园诗般的一样，所有那些，你会说有13个孙辈在周围跑来跑去，这就是我们的“超级碗”。它太美妙了。其中一个孩子家过平安夜。我们通常会办一个盛大的平安夜派对。然后我负责圣诞节早晨。那是我的传统。
And we have so many amazing traditions in our family. We celebrate, you know, Groundhog's Day. We celebrate everything. Really? We can't wait to do a party. We can't wait to celebrate somebody's special occasion or event or, you know, the kids graduating from kindergarten. or, you know, it makes life really special.
我们家有那么多美妙的传统。我们庆祝，你知道的，土拨鼠日。我们庆祝一切。真的吗？我们迫不及待地想办派对。我们迫不及待地想庆祝某人的特殊时刻或活动，或者，你知道的，孩子们从幼儿园毕业，或者，你知道的，这让生活变得非常特别。
Yeah, you keeping up on all that stuff will be a full-time job for me as it is right there. Let's just keeping up with the Kardashians. Yeah, there you go. You know, when you say your kids are, you know, like an emptiness thing and your kids are getting older and it happens so fast. And, you know, I think that it's just really important
是的，对你来说，跟进所有这些事情将是一份全职工作，就像现在这样。让我们只管跟上卡戴珊一家的脚步吧。是的，就是这样。你知道的，当你提到你的孩子们，你知道的，就像空巢的感觉，你的孩子们长大了，这一切发生得太快了。而且，你知道的，我认为非常重要的一点是，
to remember that we're just that they're not far away and just create these memories and moments as much as you can to stay connected. Because people ask me a lot, how do you raise a family? You guys are all so close, genuinely close. And, you know, I often say you just, it's not something that you can really teach.
要记住我们只是，他们并没有离得很远，只要尽可能多地创造这些记忆和时刻来保持联系。因为人们经常问我，你是怎么抚养一个家庭的？你们怎么都这么亲密，是真正意义上的亲密。而且，你知道的，我经常说，你只是，这不是那种你真正能教出来的事情。
It's something that you just have to feel and do. Yeah. I got to tell you, we've done, how many of these have we done, you guys? A couple hundred? We've done like 300? This is the first time, no joke. that I've looked at the clock and been shocked
这是一种你必须去感受并去做的事情。是的。我得告诉你，我们已经做过了，我们做过多少期这个节目了，伙计们？好几百期？我们做了大概300期？说真的，这是我第一次看表时感到震惊，
that we are at an hour 15. I know. Really? I thought we were like an hour. I thought we were like 40 minutes. First of all, I'm sorry that we're 15 minutes over. It's fine. Chloe's, I'm going to have a meeting with her
我们已经聊了一个小时十五分钟了。我知道。真的吗？我以为我们才聊了一个小时。我以为我们才聊了40分钟。首先，很抱歉我们超时了15分钟。没关系。克洛伊，我要和她开个会，
and we're filming our show, and she's probably going to walk into our studio and go, what the hell are you doing this? Before we let you go, excuse me, I want to talk about All's Fair, just for one quick sec or a long sec, if you want. The show on Hulu, executive producing on, like, so now this is scripted. Yes.
而且我们在拍我们的节目，她可能会走进我们的工作室说，你们到底在搞什么鬼？在我们让你离开之前，对不起，我想聊聊《律政群英》（All's Fair），就花一小会儿，或者一大会儿，如果你愿意的话。Hulu上的那个剧，你担任执行制片人，所以现在这是有剧本的了。是的。
And Ryan Murphy's producing, writing, directing. And this, do you prefer the scripted stuff? Do you want to mix it all in? Do you want to go, you know, how much, tell us about the ratio between scripted and unscripted going forward for you guys? So doing an unscripted show. is truly unscripted for us. We have no scripts.
而且是瑞恩·墨菲（Ryan Murphy）制片、编剧、导演。这个，你更喜欢有剧本的吗？你想把它们混合起来吗？你想去，你知道的，对于你们来说，未来有剧本和无剧本的比例大概是多少？所以拍摄一个无剧本的节目，对我们来说真的是完全无剧本。我们没有剧本。
I don't even know half the time, I'm being perfectly honest, what we're going to film that day. I'll know on my schedule, amongst all the other things I'm doing that day. It'll be glam. Kardashians is filming, you know, blah, blah, blah. Sometimes I don't know what's happening.
说实话，很多时候我甚至不知道那天我们要拍什么。我会在日程表上看到，在我要做的其他事情中间。会是化妆造型。卡戴珊一家在拍摄，你知道的，巴拉巴拉巴拉。有时我甚至不知道发生了什么。
I think, you know, I knew my crew was going to be here today because I do know that we're going to film something later and I'm working with Chloe and I think Kylie's probably here. But I'm really not sure some days, like what we're, but it always works out and it's always magic. So that's that side of it. I don't think, honestly, I could do more than one of those types of shows because it's not something that I want to manufacture what's going on. And at that point, what else is there to talk? You know, so it would have to be scripted.
我想，你知道的，我知道我的摄制组今天会来，因为我知道我们稍后要拍点东西，而且我要和克洛伊一起工作，我想凯莉可能也在。但有些时候我真的不确定，比如我们要，但事情总能顺利解决，而且总是充满魔术般的惊喜。这就是它的那一面。老实说，我觉得我无法同时拍摄一个以上这种类型的节目，因为这不是那种我想凭空捏造发生的事情的节目。到了那个地步，还有什么好聊的呢？你知道的，所以它必须是有剧本的。
So when Ryan Murphy came over for dinner one night and I said to Kim come by, because as I said, we all live down the street from each other. I said, come over. Ryan Murphy's going to come over. I'm so obsessed with him. And we love what he does and all of that. So he came over.
所以当瑞恩·墨菲有一天晚上过来吃晚饭时，我对金说，过来吧，因为正如我所说，我们都住在彼此的街区。我说，过来吧。瑞恩·墨菲要来。我太迷恋他了。我们都喜欢他的作品以及诸如此类的东西。所以他过来了。
And I remember we had a conversation. And I said, why don't, he said, why don't you, you know, to Kim, you know, maybe we could work together. And I said, Ryan, maybe write a show for her. Like, why don't you write something? Right. And we'll do something really exciting. In the meantime, he put her in American Horror Story, which she did a great job.
我记得我们有过一次交谈。我说，为什么不，他对金说，你知道的，也许我们可以合作。我说，瑞恩，也许给她写个剧吧。就像，你为什么不写点什么呢？对吧。然后我们会做一些非常令人兴奋的事情。与此同时，他让她出演了《美国恐怖故事》，她表现得非常棒。
Right. And she's not a trained actress. Right. She did phenomenal. And she got, she was happy with it. She loved the process, which I thought was a little concerning to me because there's a lot of waiting around. Yeah. There's a lot of structure.
对。而且她不是科班出身的演员。对。她表现得极其出色。而且她对此很满意。她喜欢这个过程，这让我觉得有点担心，因为里面有很多等待的时间。是的。有很多结构化的流程。
There's a lot of, it's much, much different than, oh, bring the camera over. all shoot it on my iPhone, you know, I'm doing a reality show. It's much, obviously, you guys know that better than it. You're three actors. You know, we're not actors by trade. Right. And so when she did it, she loved the process. And then I've suddenly got a call from Ryan.
有很多，这和“哦，把摄像机拿过来，我用iPhone拍个真人秀”相比，要大得多、很不一样。当然，你们比我更懂这个。你们三个是演员。你知道的，我们不是靠当演员谋生的。对。所以当她拍完后，她喜欢这个过程。然后我突然接到了瑞恩的电话。
And he said, I have something for you. And I said, hold up. Come over. Let me get my crew. So he came over to the house. We had a martini. He presented this idea for Kim, for All's Fair. And we,
他说，我有个东西给你。我说，等等。过来吧。让我叫上我的摄制组。所以他来到家里。我们喝了马提尼。他为金提出了这个想法，为了《律政群英》，我们，
love the idea. Kim signed on. They talked about who would be her co-stars. And let me tell you something, these women were so generous and kind and amazing to her and really wrap their arms around her. And Ryan Murphy surrounded her with the most incredible group of women and we had the time of our lives. She suddenly had a renewed spirit. She was making friends with people. She would never, you know, have these relationships with. And I saw her beaming, you know, and really enjoying what she was doing. And now it got picked up for season two. And it's, it's been, you know, Sarah, Sarah Paulson and Glenn Close and Tiana Taylor and Naomi Watts and Nisi Nash and Kim and this beautiful cast. Also a cast.
非常喜欢这个主意。金签约了。他们讨论了谁将是她的联合主演。我跟你讲，这些女性对她太慷慨、太善良、太棒了，真的张开双臂接纳了她。瑞恩·墨菲给她周围安排了最不可思议的一群女性，我们度过了此生最美好的时光。她突然焕发了新的精神。她开始和那些她绝不可能建立这种关系的人交朋友。我看到她容光焕发，你知道的，真正享受她正在做的事情。现在这部剧已经续订第二季了。而且，你知道的，有莎拉·保罗森（Sarah Paulson）、格伦·克洛斯（Glenn Close）、泰安娜·泰勒（Teyana Taylor）、娜奥米·沃茨（Naomi Watts）、尼西·纳什（Niecy Nash）还有金以及这个美丽的演员阵容。也是一个全明星阵容。
And the fashion that they all loved. And they just all loved hanging out with Kim. She loved hanging out with them. And I saw this genuine friendship evolve and develop over time. And it's been really, really amazing for me to get to witness that for my daughter. I'm so proud of her. That's great. Yeah.
而且她们都很喜欢里面的时尚。她们就是很喜欢和金一起玩。金也很喜欢和她们一起玩。我看到这种真挚的友谊随着时间推移而演变和发展，对于我来说，能亲眼见证女儿经历这一切，真的是非常非常了不起。我为她感到骄傲。太棒了。是的。
Really, really great. Yeah. And they're going into season two, and that's a big deal. And they start next month. So I'm really excited. And now Kim is filming her first, well, not her first movie, but a big movie that's a comedy. And it's going to be really, really good.
真的，真的很棒。是的，她们要进入第二季了，这是件大事。她们下个月开机。所以我真的很兴奋。现在金正在拍摄她的第一部，好吧，也不是她的第一部电影，而是一部大型喜剧电影。而且会非常非常棒。
It's called Fifth Wheel. Very nice. I'm glad things are finally working out for you guys. And, you know, you're starting to get a little wind at your backs. You know, we're just trying, man. It's just awesome. It's a grind. Chris, it's just, it really is incredible.
片名叫《第五轮》（Fifth Wheel）。非常好。我很高兴事情终于对你们来说渐入佳境了。而且，你知道的，你们开始顺风顺水了。你知道的，我们只是在努力，伙计。这简直太棒了。这是一种煎熬，克里斯，这真的太不可思议了。
I'm so, so thankful that you came on and you spent more than an hour with us telling us how you've done it all and how you continue to do it all. And we're rooting for you and we'll be watching all the next years going forward with this incredible story, truly. I appreciate you guys so much. And thank you for being so lovely and supportive. and I'm just grateful to be a part of this, you know, life and the entertainment community and to be able to add a little something. And I just, I come from a place of incredible gratitude. So for everybody that watches our show or has given us any kind of support or kindness
我真的，真的非常感谢你能来，并花了一个多小时给我们讲述你是如何做到这一切的，以及你是如何继续做到这一切的。我们在为你加油，我们会在未来几年里一直关注这个不可思议的故事，真的。非常感谢你们。谢谢你们这么可爱和支持我，我只是很感激能成为这种生活和娱乐社区的一部分，并且能够为此增添一点价值。而且我带着无比感恩的心态来到这里。所以对于每一个观看我们的节目、或者给予我们任何支持和善意的人，
or just, you know, just, you know, being watching from afar, it means the world. And, you know, I think that, you know, It's just, it's great to be and come from a place of gratitude and just be kind to each other. Yeah, well, our audience is certainly grateful for what you've done. Well, we love you. We love you. Yeah. Love you guys so much.
或者只是，你知道的，仅仅是在远处观看的人，这对我而言意味着整个世界。而且，你知道的，我认为，能保持并来自一颗感恩的心，对彼此善良，这真的很棒。是的，我们的观众当然对你所做的一切心怀感激。好吧，我们爱你们。我们爱你们。是的。非常爱你们。
Thank you. Thank you so much. Thank you so much. And Jason, I can't wait for our next vacation with Amanda. Yeah, yeah, yeah. Us too. Okay. Okay, we'll plan it out.
谢谢。非常感谢。非常感谢。杰森，我等不及和阿曼达进行我们的下一次假期了。对，对，对。我们也是。好的。好的，我们来计划一下。
Okay, good. All right. All right. All right. Thank you very much. Bye, guys. Thanks, Chris. Bye, honey.
好的，太好了。行。行。行。非常感谢。再见，伙计们。谢谢你，克里斯。再见，亲爱的。
See ya. Bye. Bye. Bye. Wow. Yeah. Powerhouse. Honestly, I didn't, I did not realize the time. I could have listened to her, explain it all for even longer. She's so well-spoken and succinct. There's so much more to that story too, right? Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Dang it.
再见。再见。再见。哇。是的。真的是个能量 powerhouse。说实话，我没有，我真的没有注意到时间。我可以听她解释这一切更长时间。她太会说话了，而且言简意赅。这个故事背后还有更多内容，对吧？是的。是的。是的。该死。
And, you know, when I feel like lazy or something, like, look at her, man. I know. Like, what? Her days, she's starting at five in the morning and probably goes till 10,000. 10 at night on something that you just can't phone in. Right? I mean, the switch has got to be flicked on and she is just running shit. I mean, if I have like two things in my day that I've got to like focus on, I'm like, oh, damn it.
而且，你知道的，当我感到懒惰或者别的什么的时候，就像，看看她，天哪。我知道。就像，什么？她的日子，她早上五点开始，可能一直忙到晚上十点，做着那些你根本无法应付了事的事情。对吧？我的意思是，开关必须一直开着，她简直在掌控一切。我的意思是，如果我一天中有两件必须专注的事，我就会想，哦，该死。
Like, when can I put my PJs back on? If it's after 4 o'clock, it's just, oh. I'm kidding. But yeah, like the whole, I love the entrepreneur. and the philanthropy and she's just a cool hang. Yeah. I like her. And, you know, she's so unique.
就像，我什么时候才能把睡衣穿回去？如果过了下午四点，就，哦。我开玩笑的。不过，是的，就像整个，我喜欢她的企业家精神还有慈善事业，而且她本人就是一个很酷、很好相处的人。是的。我喜欢她。而且，你知道的，她是如此独特。
Uh-oh. She's so unique and she's so different. It's really like one in a million. She's really, she's like a human being that's not, it's not easy to come by. Bye. That's the sentence. Come by. It's not easy to come by.
噢哦。她是如此独特，又如此与众不同。这真的是千里挑一。她真的，她就像是一个不好遇到的人。再见。就是这句话。不好遇到。
Okay. Yeah, someone like her is not easy to come by. There you are. Smartless. Smartless is 100% organic and artisanly handcrafted by Rob Armjarf, Bennett Barbico, and Michael Grant Terry.
好吧。是的，像她这样的人可不好找。这就是全部。Smartless。Smartless由Rob Armjarf、Bennett Barbico和Michael Grant Terry 100%有机且以手工精心打造。
Smartless. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
Smartless。本期节目暂无评论。点击字幕中的任意句子即可发表评论。